Yeah.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe,
what does that mean?
God,
170 fucking episodes and I'm
still keeping my laptop power on.
It's ridiculous.
Um,
we brought to you by the flashlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link entering the code name,
Rogan,
and a,
you will get 15% off the
number one sex toys for men.
It was a tight race between
number one and number two.
What was the other one?
Ham.
Melons.
We sliced ham.
Whatever it is,
do it or don't do it.
They're just a sponsor folks.
But it's a good product if
you're into masturbating,
if you're going to do it,
and you probably are,
this is better than just doing it.
It's technology.
Okay.
Embrace the times.
We were also brought to you by [inaudible]
Dot Com oh and it makers of Alpha
brain,
and we have a new alpha
brain that's coming out.
It's called Alpha brain source for all
you folks in the UK that have much more
restrictive laws when it comes
to nutritional supplements.
Like they can't even get vitamin B six
over there and some in some places in
Europe.
That's right.
The strange rent.
Yeah.
So our Alpha brain was considered a drug,
so it takes it out.
Does it put anything else in?
No.
Well it's just different.
The alternative ingredients that have
a similar effects and so we're still
fucking with it right now.
Hipster ingredients.
It's,
you know,
it might be better for some people that
find the original Alpha brain is hard to
take.
Like some people get nauseous from it
and some people doesn't make them feel
good.
It's,
it's,
it's real weird.
Everybody has a different,
everybody has a different
biological setup,
you know,
I feel like I was a
little sensitive to it.
Yeah.
But I took a lot that was
the issue take too much.
And I took two in the morning,
two at night and I
think that was too much.
Three once in one dose,
three or four in one dose or forgotten.
And I did not feel good.
And I was like,
maybe this is what people
feel like all the time.
Everybody's got a different
tolerance for caffeine,
for anything.
But for me too is good.
I take two Alpha brains and it's uh,
it's just,
it's not that shit from that movie.
What is it with Bradley Cooper?
It's just vitamins that
enhance cognitive function.
It's all,
it is enhance.
Just like vitamins enhance your health.
It's very subtle but effective.
I enjoy it.
And the most important thing about
any of the Onnit products is there's a
hundred percent money back guarantee.
You don't have to return the product.
Just say it didn't work for you
and you get all your money back.
And we tried to make this
thing as fair as possible.
If you think it's too expensive,
I urge you please,
if you're interested in
nootropics to go online,
Google the subject,
look into it.
There's a lot of interesting studies
behind it and I personally have been
studying them and experimenting with
it for a long time now and I like it.
I liked the effects and if
you think that that on it,
Alpha brain is too expensive,
go to the website and
steal the ingredient list.
Just look at it's all online.
The exact amounts were online.
Go buy in bulk and make your
own stuff and I hope it works.
I swear to God,
I am way more concerned with people
not feeling ripped off than I am up for
making money.
That's why we make it as easy as possible.
100% money back guarantee too.
Don't forget that,
so enjoy it or don't enjoy it,
but there's a bunch of cool
products that we have out
now.
One of them is called shroom tech sport
and it's excellent for anybody who's
really into working out.
If you're really in,
if you do anything that's
like super strenuous,
you know you're,
you know you're doing running or like
some serious weightlifting class or
something like that.
Anything you do will you
really exert yourself.
It's an amazing supplement.
It's great for Jujitsu.
I love it for,
for any kind of athletic stuff,
but if you're not in the work in Alec,
Bryan doesn't even take that shit.
Doesn't help.
Yo-Yoing does this doesn't help us.
Yoyo Games.
We also have a shroom tech.
What would the shrimp tech is based on
all the information that's at [inaudible]
dot com [inaudible] dot com but it's
based on the quarter steps mushroom,
which is a mushroom that actually enhances
your body's ability to process oxygen
and people like,
and a higher climates and animals in
higher climates eat it and they actually
get energy and they,
that's how they figured
out that this stuff works.
Um,
we also have a shroom tech immune,
which is a,
an immune supplement.
And basically the way this one works,
what as it's been explained to me is
your body doesn't understand what this
mushroom is when it thinks it may be
like a bug thinks you may be sick,
so your body's immune system fires
up for a fight that never comes.
Right?
And so then your immune system
is just like on full tilt,
you know,
it's,
it pumps it up,
which it's a really,
I'm,
I'm real into probiotics.
I drink Kombucha tea every day.
I take Acidophilus,
um,
I take live cultures.
That's why cutters and ever get sick
cutters and like people that can throw
stuff themselves and their
body thinks they're dying.
So really it didn't make sense.
I guess that would be amazing match
if that's what you get up to do.
We would never get sick.
Just give yourself a little cut every day.
Yeah,
I don't think it works out.
Let me try it.
Yeah.
Um,
we also have a new mood,
which is a five HTP supplement,
which is a little serotonin booster.
And uh,
again,
like I said,
please study all this stuff online.
100% money back guarantee.
Always end.
Right now you have a special coupon,
don't you?
I saw what the fuck is that even
stand for the special coupon is worth,
it's 2012 so it's 20.2 12%
20 point 12% law.
But what was the coupon code?
Actually I was trying to figure it out.
I was like,
like I said,
and it's in,
well I'll tell you right now it's,
and why are sending like
20 years Rogan's I dunno.
What the fuck is stands for?
Not Your New Year,
New Year maybe it's like texting,
like tech speak.
Yeah.
It's probably something that kids like do.
And we're like old man,
like let and Ayi.
Yeah.
These kids these days.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
I dunno.
Let me,
let me make sure I get the,
the,
the actual thing right.
I got it somewhere.
He should never young guns now.
Never.
Dammit.
I should have this right in front of me,
but I don't,
it's not your tweeter.
I know what I can't find it.
Tweet that shit.
And why are and why our
2012 or just 12,012 no,
Nyer 12 that's it.
And why are 12 wow,
we're organized as fuck.
Sorry.
Well that's the end of
these stupid commercials,
right?
Go to Joe Rogan battling that.
Click the link and read and decode
named Rogan get 10% but don't do that.
Do the
other one and why are get
yourself 20 point 12% off.
That's it.
It's over.
And that was,
it was brutal for me too.
All right gentlemen and ladies and
everybody else that's tuning in.
Peter Joseph is here.
You get to the bottom of shit.
[inaudible]
we're going to get to the obvious shit.
First of all,
before we even started this interview,
I want to tell you that I'm
ready to join your cult.
I've gone online,
I've,
I've seen other cult
members and leaders before.
They're not nearly as charismatic as you.
They don't make as much sense as you,
I think you're on point
and I'm ready to sign up.
You just tell me what I need to.
Uh,
you're,
you're a utopian view of the perfect
society is fucking brilliant,
man.
It's a,
it's,
it's dead on Peter Joseph.
You don't know is the creative,
it's like I used the,
the or the original movie and then
all these followup movies and now it's
actually,
you know,
you refer to it as a movement
and that's not cocky in any way,
shape or form.
That's just what it is.
It's a movement,
you know,
so the zeitgeists movement that,
Tz em on Twitter,
that Tz movement on Twitter,
um,
and it's,
a,
a fascinating thing
that's going on right now.
And your movies and your movement,
I mean,
can you say it's yours now?
Now it's sort of like it's
become a life of its own right?
No owns it.
And,
and whether people like it or not,
they're a part of the zeitgeists
movement one way or another.
What does the zeitgeists movement?
It's the definition of the times.
It's the cultural nuance of Ivy.
This is all the shit that we believe
and think it's true and how we progress
through time.
Hence the Zike guys movement.
So whether we,
anyone likes it or not,
they're part of the Zeitgeists boob.
So I just brought that into
that particular context.
How did you become this
smooth talk bad motherfucker?
How did this happen?
How did you become this guy?
Because it's not just that you
have all these great ideas.
It's a,
you never use the word awesome.
All right.
You just sail through the sentences
and you're just like your musician.
Is that what your background is?
I am a musician with percussionists,
classical percussionists.
That's what I tried to
do for years and years,
but didn't fit in the whole orchestral
establishment percussion scene.
Now,
Brett percussion in enlightened me exists.
It's not just,
it's not drunk.
It's drums.
You have the mallet family,
then there's the kettle
drums like Timpani.
Then you have hand portion and
learn the mall as much as I could.
Given the time that I have
in my studio in Culver City,
I have full section of my little house
blocked off or whenever I can pursue my
old hobby again,
which seems to be less and less.
Unfortunately.
People listen to me.
Some of your stuff online,
so I'm,
I'm working on compiling.
I've been hesitant to do that because
my identity has been so bizarre as a
filmmaker,
which I'd never intended to be.
Actually,
I think I sent you the link of the first
Zike guys performance a performance.
It wasn't intended to be a documentary
in the sense formulaically as you would
traditionally assumed,
which is how did it morph?
What happened?
Well,
I had the 2007 I did a six night
run in lower Manhattan free,
who was a thing.
I spent a lot of money on prepared this
piece over the course of seven months.
Didn't expect it to go anywhere because
basically I had no rights to actually
pursue this as a film.
So this is a firm firmly one shot off,
fair use type of deal.
So I did it,
publicized it,
people came,
everything was cool,
everyone liked it.
It was very dramatic.
He has some people walked out
and people really liked it.
Some inspired Q.
And.
A.
It was a catharsis for me.
I was in advertising,
I was doing shit that I didn't
appreciate doing is what the system does,
you know,
it forces you into a particular pocket
for the most of us for a lot of,
we don't necessarily
enjoy what we're doing.
So this is a catharsis.
And the unique thing about
it is it was so honest.
This is a very honest work from me.
I didn't really think about
approaching a demographic.
And when I,
when it went online on
Google video before youtube,
this is when Google video was the only
Internet video site that actually had
full length stuff.
And very rarely you'd hear about
feature length films getting there.
And I just happened to hit that paradigm
right then and it went crazy viral and
the lawsuits were threatened and everyone
thought it was some big documentary,
big production.
They had no idea that
background of lawsuits or
threaten the people that are in
it.
You know,
that film was a fair use film.
It was not intended to be released.
So whenever people saw like 20,
30 million views in the first year of
when seeing dollar signs as though,
and I wasn't even selling anything,
I wasn't intending to.
And then eventually I went back,
you know,
the tail between my legs
with all these people that,
cause the whole thing is full.
The whole thing is a
montage of the zeitgeists.
It's just one big cluster of all sorts
of different personalities kind of mushed
together.
And most of them supported it.
And then some of them got a little greedy
but everyone got paid off for the most
part.
And there's still a few
rocks left unturned,
but the statute of
limitations is now up on that.
So if anyone wants to sue me,
you're going to have the greater,
uh,
effect the ass.
Yeah.
Well it isn't all just stuff that
is out there in the public record.
Essentially.
It is,
but you know,
and put it together.
Anybody can sue anybody for anything if
they think they can get money out of it.
Especially in the film and
the film and media industry.
So you obviously you surprised by
the response to the first film you,
you had no idea any of
this was going to happen.
I had no intention to make a second film.
I never considered myself a filmmaker.
It was always musically driven and then
a denim came out in 2008 and that was,
that was picked up by the art of his
film festivals shown here at the Egyptian
theater.
That had a huge response.
Even larger in a certain sense because
it was the first time it had been
publicly displayed,
this whole phenomenon and then that
carried over into the zeitgeists movement,
which was basically the,
the thought experiment I had is like,
okay,
we have these film series.
He had plenty of people like
Michael Moore and making films.
Do they really support change or are
they really doing anything to actually
initiate a community effort
to get something going?
And at that point in time,
I had no idea what that would actually be.
It was I did,
I,
I figured,
well it says in the
movie on if he remembers,
I coasted end up,
it says join the movement,
start the largest critical
mass the world's ever seen
to try and get some change
going and it seemed to take root.
And then from there it's
been this kind of bubbling,
changing and morphine kind
of phenomenon that's global.
Now the zeitgeists movement,
which is,
which is a shared community.
I want to make people understand it isn't
like a movement than any the world's
ever seen.
This is just the people that the group
of people would have a similar value set.
That's the only way I describe it.
It's the ultimate anti institution.
So I often don't even
reference the movement.
I referenced the ideas behind it.
So you make this documentary,
it gets out and then all the sudden you
realize that there's this crazy movement
behind it.
And how do you attempt to organize it?
How do you attempt,
do you not do just get out of its
way and let it organize itself?
Like sort of an occupy
Wall Street types of it.
Combination of the two.
We started off at a self organizing
capacity but volunteers from around the
world,
it was beautiful actually just getting
all this communication from different
demographics.
I mean the whole is like our spectrum.
The audience if you will,
for not just the fillings with for the
movement that it paid attention to these
ideas is totally vast.
Yet people that are,
I've met kids that are like 10 years
old with a little zeitgeists move a tee
shirt on up to 80 year
old men that you know,
they're looking for something
different so it's amazing.
And the ethnicity differences are massive.
Want to be in Israel next
month giving a lecture.
It's truly unique.
So it self organized.
As it began we started to pinpoint
different coordination positions.
People in charge
places and give lectures as well.
I do.
And what is like,
what is the,
the lecture essentially,
uh,
is it just you breaking down how this
got started or is it you talk about yeah,
your perspective while they usually it's
lectures broken into three released now
lecture,
spoken to three typical lectures broken
into the first part being what defines
awareness and logic.
And reason how we think about information.
We're dismissing the Messenger.
Gotta look at it logically.
X,
Y,
and Z's.
Forget,
forget the subjects.
It's all about the train of thought
that the process of thought is,
is irrespective of personality.
There's a huge conflict in society
between logic and psychology and they're
very,
very different and I can
expand on that as we go.
Second Section is the criticism of
the current socioeconomic platform,
which I consider to be
one massive corruption.
We talk about corruption.
You'll a hard drive corrupts.
It's messed up or criminal,
political and Rob's a convenience store.
It's a corruption of the system,
the socioeconomic system,
the legal system.
To me,
the entire socioeconomic system,
namely economic,
not only politics,
politics is an outgrowth,
but I won't jump on that.
One is a is one massive corruption of
what it means to live on this planet,
what it means to perfect
good public health.
So there's that section he had stay in Ed.
That's massive and it must the
criticisms and presentations I do.
Then there's the solution which
support the train of thought,
which has many different names
as far as a new social system,
which I don't even
really address any more.
I'd just like to go for
the train of thought.
And what it comes down to is
you have to have a system,
a system that's based on
planetary resource management,
very fundamental stuff.
By the way,
a system that's not based on
growth and all the strange,
infinite growth paradigm stuff.
I'm sure my resource manager,
whole community,
one giant community
gets together and says,
okay,
what do we need and how
do we keep everybody happy
globally,
globally?
And you think about it in
the broadest symbiotic sense.
You know,
like one of the great
psychological revelations,
intellectual revelations that we've had
as species is that is that we've been
living in these divisive
kind of tribalistic concepts
and we assume normality
with it because of how
long they persisted.
But we tend to find that what we find
now as far as information is concerned,
is that we live in a global system.
We live in a symbiosis.
There's stretches outward,
honest to infinity.
So the very idea of separation because
literally tangibly on applicable to the
way we approach our life,
where we approached knowledge,
the way we approach approach society,
the way we approach economics,
which is the defining
feature of our existence.
You know,
how we get what we need,
how we relate,
of course,
how it,
the renewable elements,
the regeneration,
if you will,
the Omni regeneration or as a
Buckminster fuller of everything.
How do we respect that?
And the ultimate realization is that
we have to begin to unify all concepts.
You see this and intellectual things.
Consilience is a book by Edward O.
Wilson.
Early on in the 1980s he wrote about
this concept of all the the disciplines
starting to merge together.
So you can't talk about chemistry without
talking about biology or other way
around.
You can't talk about physics that
are talking about mathematics.
You can't separate anything anymore.
And that's a unique phenomenon that's
occurring and you can stretch that train
of thought backwards and forwards
in my approach as far as simplicity,
the economic system has to be unified.
It has to have a very simple respect
of what actually supports us.
I can ramble that.
How did that transition take place?
We need,
even if you were to engineer the perfect
Utopian mathematic formula for keeping
everybody no such thing,
what do you do with the
money that you have now?
Does it just dissolved?
We start from scratch,
like,
you know,
how does that work?
How does it transition from,
from one monetary system
that makes no sense.
Where there's massive amounts of
corruption and people with huge amounts of
resources that they've probably gotten by.
What would be considered immoral,
although legal ways.
Sure.
What do you do with their money?
Well,
there's a few few answers to that one.
Let's,
let's get rid of the
word that Utopian though.
I mean,
I don't mean that in a sense of a fantasy
that's impossible of being achieved.
I mean,
it is an ideal like a boulder,
Colorado.
As far as what friend
of mine said to me once,
it's a working utopia and I believe it is,
you know,
I don't mean it in a sense of impossible.
Okay.
You put utopia is a touchy word.
I like the word sometimes
it's just missed is finite
only the best that we know up until
now and the great flaws that we're not
actually doing anything based
on the knowledge we have today.
But to answer your question,
how do we do that?
You know,
how do we transition?
The system is failing.
You have an unemployment crisis,
we have a debt crisis and we have a,
um,
and we have a energy
crisis that's looming.
Three of the nails in the
coffin as far as I'm concerned,
that interweave in certain ways.
We also have another crisis.
And that crisis is the
way people raise children.
We have the crisis of,
you know,
too many people that don't give a fuck
about their kids and they're raising
these little problems,
these people that are,
you know,
and the crisis of
consciousness means for sure.
And that absolutely transmits
from parent to children.
You know,
when,
when they're not paying attention to the
kids or where they're bad parenting or
you know,
whatever they have.
Well that brings up the,
he gets the same sort of,
it's like how do we change?
They're there.
How do we change society
at the Cork is really,
you got to get to them too.
That's a big percentage of people that
are impoverished and uneducated and strip
clubs.
It's great for a lot of things.
It's great for porn too.
Yeah.
Just we want a lot of chaos,
you know,
and you want a lot of messy things.
Great for fighting too.
Um,
but I think that's,
that's a big problem,
right?
I mean,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Hence the nature of what the zeitgeists
wound that really defines itself as me.
You can talk about these
solution oriented things,
but really it's the,
it's the evolution of human awareness.
The real crisis is the
crisis of ignorance.
There's no energy crisis.
It's really just a crisis of
misunderstanding what we're doing
and the fact that people have become
addicted to the money that's going around
the,
the people that are taking
money from corporations,
it's,
it stopped becoming a matter of
whether or not it's a good thing.
It's,
it's precedented.
There's a precedent.
It's already in place.
They're making the money.
They're going to continue to make the
money and then want to make the money.
And so anything where you say,
well,
hey man,
I don't think that what
we're doing is really fair.
I mean,
we're being unfairly
influenced by corporations.
Uh,
dude,
we're making this fucking money.
We've been making this money,
we're going to continue
to make this money.
You don't just stop,
you know,
it's,
it's very difficult.
Dot.
That's why the failure is so important,
if you will.
The failure that's an
on hand is not going to,
is not going to be altered by any new
legislations or any fail safes the
establishment might have.
There's no way this system can persist
for a number of different reasons I could
throw out there,
first of all,
the of occupy movement,
right?
Everyone says maybe that
at this point in time,
the division of,
of rich versus poor is
more than it ever was.
Actually.
It's not.
It's always been structurally classed.
There's a structural classes and built
into this system occupies only been the
first to really acknowledged
that on the global scale of a,
a,
uh,
an issue that's been there from the very
beginning because every element of this
system supports that annex getting worse.
We live in a plutonomy now there's more
money moving amongst the upper five
percentile influencing GDP.
So much money that it makes the
lower percentiles movements and money
irrelevant.
So on it from a firmly
economic standpoint,
the lower classes are literally
irrelevant to the function of the economy.
Therefore to the,
to the powers that be,
if you will,
to the corporate establishment and to the
taxation fueling and big business that
fuels all government.
And this is all because the
system has been manipulated.
Yeah,
no,
this
is because the system is intrinsically
flawed base based on the need for
differential advantage and
an old form of tribalism,
psychological tribalism that
you have to gain advantage over.
Others is socially Darwinistic
view and what's unique.
Even though I hold that to be self
evident and true to the human condition,
if we're,
if we were both existing and extreme
scarcity and we had nothing to eat,
we end up finding each other
most likely to survive.
That's a natural human instinct.
What's happened now though is that the,
I'm jumping ahead here but following
me is that the entire infrastructure of
society,
the human population is so large,
their industry has become so big.
We have the Fukushima meltdown,
we have the nuclear weapons,
we have nano weapons
that are on the horizon.
What we have now is we can't have the
risk of this type of mentality being the
forefront of our psychology.
We can't have the self betterment of
the individual to be the forefront of us
because it goes against our
longterm evolutionary fitness,
which means the entire species at risk.
So to put it in a sentence,
the self interest that tends to
dominate now that's that really is the
psychological fuel of all
the motivations that you see.
The greed,
if fuel's degrees,
just an extension of the,
the basic motivation is
really no such thing as greed.
It's just they're in the system.
All of that that you see is going to
fuck us all up until we begin to realize
that we can't operate this way
cause it's going to destroy us.
Does that make sense?
We nuclear war was the best example.
They don't,
you don't need passports to a CEO.
The fallout,
you know,
nuclear winter would have
taken over the entire planet.
If the U S and uh,
Russia went to nuclear war,
even a minor war,
it would have destroyed almost
the entire human species.
And a few scientists realize that said,
you know what?
This isn't really a partisan or a
country or nationalist issue anymore.
This is a life issue.
So the greater our technology,
the greater our ability,
the greater vulnerability we have.
And the more clear it becomes how we
have to unify and make our self interest
become social interest if we
intend to survive as a species.
And this is the great paradigm
shift of all human thought.
So what do you do with all the weapons?
Well,
you get rid of them,
dismantle them and hope you can
regurgitate them into something defective.
Imagine if we were to take over the
Pentagon and use their equipment for
monitoring the earth's resources.
Use the amazing surveillance equipment
to actually have a productive use.
It would be incredible.
I think everything you say is brilliant
and I agree with it 100% but when I
think about it being
implemented in today's society,
I think of the human beings that exist
right now and how they've been running
their lives based on greed,
real greed based on real ignorance,
based on violence.
I mean you're going to get these people
and everybody is going to go hold hands
and sing Kumbaya together.
You know?
I feel like there has to be something,
you know there,
there has to be some sort
of event that unites people.
There's not going to be a stopping
of the separation of rich and poor.
The rich are only going to get
richer and smaller and smaller.
And when,
if you want to see anger,
just wait.
Just wait.
Where are we?
Haven't even touched the
anger stage as it were.
When you say that is what's going to start
the initial transition into something
new and the point of the movement really
is not to try to initiate some step by
step logical transition to assume human
beings are rational and they're just
going to say,
oh,
that sounds better.
That sounds more efficient now that that's
not the way the human being works at
all,
at least at this stage.
So the failure will happen is like I said,
movements on the sidelines
as far as I'm concerned,
trying to spread information about what
a new social system may be exposing the
roots of this system and as
this tipping point occurs,
those that are on the outs will slowly
become on the end and you'll have a very
powerful large,
complicated revolution that
will happen one way or another.
I had this and it's an
inevitability to me,
so all the rich 1.0% doesn't matter.
Many billions of dollars they have the
police are not going to protect them.
There's going to be a very unique
unpredictable shift in the human social
structure.
It's a fucking movie,
isn't it?
It is.
Isn't it an a movie?
I mean really a great time in the movie
of its time when things get really
exciting.
I've said about the occupy
movement that to me,
they're like white blood cells.
They don't know exactly why they're there,
but they know that there's an issue
and they've the immune system,
there's a beer,
there's a sickness here.
Social Disorder.
It's a social immune system response.
It really is.
I mean they just clogged up all
the areas where there's corruption.
Yeah,
it's fascinating.
It was a beautiful action.
Too Bad,
the majority of the occupy movement
hasn't been able to really put a train of
thought forward that others can grasp.
They have all this media,
all this press.
I tried to,
I don't know if you've seen anything
that I've tried to do with them.
I've done,
I've done some talks in La in New York
and just really trying to get some seeds
planted as far as what a
new social structure may be.
Cause he can complain all day until you
put down to some fundamental logical
elements that people can grab,
expand and get into the
public consciousness into
the Zeitgeists we're doomed
until that happens.
This is going to be one iteration of,
of rogue.
You know,
the idea would be amazing to have uh,
an entire culture filled with cool
people and everybody works together.
Like,
boy,
you feel like,
could that work?
Is that possible?
And if it was possible when
anybody ever get anything done,
would there be any more competition?
Would they be any more
creativity with everybody just be
banging each other and
giving each other hugs.
The Fun thing about modern,
a sociological research is that a great
number of studies have been done in
those issues.
Yeah.
Incentive is a,
has been a large forest of the market
system to assume if we're doing mechanical
stuff yet I'm going to be on a conveyor
line which can easily be automated now.
And you know,
be on a subway line.
It just blows my mind.
I'm walking into like a subway restaurant
and there's this conveyor belt of
people that you could automate in five
seconds if you want to wasting their
lives.
Yeah,
you have to pay people for that.
But when it comes to creativity,
very few are actually motivated by
money and money actually inhibits.
There's longer studies that are done
by man named Daniel Pink called drive.
I recommend that book to
anyone that's interested.
I would think that,
yeah,
if you were just concentrating
on money and you would,
that you would lose part of your
mental resources that you could have
concentrated on creativity.
So deep in inhibition,
everything I've ever done creatively
have never money's a pollutant to me.
You know,
for anything that I've done pollutant,
it hinders my creative response.
Really.
A fucker.
You a hundred percent fucking love money.
I love buying cool shit.
I like going to movies.
I like going to dinner and I don't
have to worry how much it costs.
You hate money,
period.
I hate money,
I hate not to do limitless resources.
Yeah.
If I just didn't have,
well,
we're dealing with it.
I hate dealing with bills.
You hate it.
I
hate having money.
I hate getting motherfucker.
I hate having to deal with that part.
I just like waking up
doing what I wanted to do.
Creativity like,
like,
like not having to worry about
that at all would be amazing
because they'll just go somewhere and
give them your pictures and they give you
some meat.
Well,
I mean again,
like of course that you
have to get paid he to live,
but if that I could take
that whole part out,
that'd be amazing.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's the system that we're,
it's not,
it's absolutely not the best we can do.
You know?
There's,
there's no way this is the best we can do,
especially the stock market.
Man.
I don't give a fuck if
you understand it or not.
I watch it.
Sometimes I watch those numbers scroll
through the bottom of screen and there's
some fucking dude with his,
his classical attire has traditional
attire that he's wearing with his tie and
his his and he's moving
around and pointing totally.
These different stocks are
going up and down and you know,
it's all based on confidence though.
What kind of a shitbag
system have you put together?
What kind of a Goofy fucking number game?
What's all going up and down
and shorts and derivatives?
You tell me what the fuck did
derivative market is again,
why is it a hundred times
bigger than the real market?
What?
Well,
as much as I hate to admit it,
I was a private equity trader for
about six years after I left was like,
well,
it was a personal choice to
get out of the establishment.
You know,
the only occupation in existence we don't
have a boss or a client or reliant on
an audience is in the equity trading.
So were you,
uh,
is it like being an educated guesser?
Is that what it's like?
There's a huge strategy that's called
technical analysis that people use.
It's now it's automated behind the scenes
by groups like Goldman Sachs that are
raping.
Everybody's slowly but surely.
But no,
there's it from Ted.
I had a lot of respect for the traders
independently because of their mindset.
It's a great discipline.
It's like a sport you really
have to know you're doing.
You can't just wing it,
it's not gambling.
And then he kind of sense like that.
But as an institution,
those stock market and the whole concept
of these representations of equity and
finance and how and how much
influence it has in society,
and of course the Dalit driven is blow
out and everything else that we've seen,
it's the most cancerous thing
on the face of the earth.
It stock market.
It's just unbelievable.
That's why it even exists at all.
I have no clue.
It's the ultimate manifestation of
the worst concept of having no social
contribution and invariably making
more money than any other sector of the
population.
Even though you create nothing,
you'd do nothing.
And it's just like Wall
Street and Michael Douglas.
He's like,
you know,
it's like I create nothing I own.
Yeah,
it's amazing that it's been able to
get to the point where it is now.
It's just what a what an out
of control ride and you guys,
they may like $40 million
a year doing nothing.
Nothing.
And you say to yourself,
well,
here's the market system.
This is the capitalist concept,
right?
Oh everyone.
If you do the most contribution,
you supposed to get the most reward.
That's the underlying tone.
So if you work really hard and didn't
really want to and make that invention,
then you can contribute to society.
Now it's you better go.
You're only off of yourself.
Fuck everybody else.
That's what's rewarded in the system
across the board and the market system is
just the highest level of that
psychological manifestation.
Did it grow
too fast for our little monkey minds?
Is that what it is?
Did Technology and the concept of
being able to control money and all the
different things that we have to deal
with is variables didn't exist when our
minds are were created.
Our DNA is essentially the same
as it was 10,000 years ago.
It's our DNA.
It's really essentially set up for the
natural world and then all of a sudden
we've shoved it into this weird new
dimension where we're dealing with an
incredible amount of variables.
You're dealing with
all kinds of craziness.
I mean,
it's just,
I don't know if the mind is set up to
deal with the world that we've created,
which is why it's like a
kid at the helm of a car.
It does not drive and he
stopped on the fucking gas,
but he's too small to look over the over
the dashboard so it is even know where
the fuck he's going.
He's trying to figure this
thing out as he goes along.
It's like all of a sudden
this little kid has a car,
you know?
And that's what it's like with us.
Like we're like these dumb
fucking monkeys and we're,
we're still evolving out of that dumb
monkey primal soup and popping out where
we're at.
This monkey that's aware of itself.
And then in the process of
becoming aware of itself,
barely getting our shit together,
we've created everything.
We've created nuclear fucking bombs and
cell phones and video that you can get a
little screening your pocket and the
ability to do things that we would have
never thought possible.
Just 50607080100 years ago.
Sure.
It's almost like no one
could have managed this.
It's almost like it blew up sure.
Faster than our reasoning.
Evolution is always
natural one way or another.
Whether we destroy ourselves well
then I guess the human species was
evolutionary culdesac
it's one way or another.
Everything is always right.
You know what I mean?
There's no wrongs here,
but you know the,
the disorder that's in place
in society is what concerns me,
which is what you alluded
to at the beginning.
You have this huge disorder based on
the system that's basically a self
destructive system.
It's not respected.
Any general variables
of resource management,
it's not respecting,
you know,
I saw a recent status at,
Oh,
China has less uh,
unemployment than America
because they're lax EPA,
if you were wherever they have in China,
the lax environmental issues,
like we should be more like China and
reduce our environmental things and they
have like huge smog thing and it's
just disgusting destroying ourselves.
One town where they say it's like
smoking two packs of cigarettes a day,
just living there.
The skies were like dark gray.
So it's,
it's a disorder that we don't even see
it and we just keep killing ourselves.
Whether it's
why is that?
Is it because we still recognize ourselves
as individuals and we still haven't
realized that we are a part of a giant
super organism that is the human race.
So because people are acting as
individuals and then they could do so as a
corporation and do so without guilt.
They act as individuals
all going towards one goal,
but under the guise that the company's
doing it in the best interest of business
and then they're able to get away with
a lot of shit that you just can't get
away with in a,
in a one on one basis
instead of thinking of
human beings as a whole.
Putting that at the front
of your ethic,
that's like not even a consideration.
It's like what can we get away with?
What's legal?
Yeah.
You know,
and it's not our fault if it's legal,
go back.
I go back to my early life.
I had a normal upbringing,
but I,
I did all sorts of shit out of college
that was highly illegal reselling things.
Just it was whatever you
can do to make money,
it didn't matter.
And everyone did too.
It was whatever you
needed to do to get money.
And what's happened now with the value
system disorder is that since that's the
pursuit,
that's the divine drive of the system.
That's what status is defined by its
what your success is defined by that.
Everyone can blindly look the other way
with how much destruction is occurring
in the world.
They can look the other way with
the wars and the cancers and,
and the just every natural phenomenon
that we've come to to disintegrate the,
all the trash that's surrounding
the planet right now.
And
like in the war too,
the way people react,
if you know that someone in their
family has been molesting someone,
it's almost like they don't want
to know the Lord looking away.
They don't want to think about it.
They don't want to do it that way.
If there was right next door,
we'd be thinking about
it every fucking day.
The fact that people can just commonly
accept the fact that there's no for,
for no reason whatsoever that
you could ever argue we're,
we have thousands of dudes with guns
in some other part of the world and it
seems normal,
doesn't it?
And it seems normal because it's a part
of life and people are born into this
normality.
They don't know any better.
So exactly.
So it is what it is because we feel
like the system must be smarter than us.
I mean it's,
it's big,
it's huge,
it's gigantic,
you know,
but it's a,
but it's a group of Goddamn individuals
with their own personal interest at hand
and their personal interests will extend
to killing people and profiting off of
it if they can get away with it.
My favorite example of that concept
was remember the movie network,
which I have little skit mad as hell
number when they got frustrated the very
end because they were losing money with
the character and they sit around and
they go,
well we could kill him.
And he you think is the audience
member that they're just joking.
You think someone that runs on the go,
yeah,
whatever,
but then they're like,
well,
if we do it,
we have to be very careful.
Then the film ends right there.
So you think about that logic,
a human life becomes quite
secondary to the most,
the motivations,
especially the higher you go up in
this sort of corporate neuroses.
Well,
you know,
it's why I've argued
before with people about,
you know,
this,
this September 11th especially that the,
I mean I've heard more
conversations about,
you know,
what people think happened September 11th
and I believe this and I believe that.
And from,
from the very moment I've said,
you don't believe that they'd be willing.
I'm not saying that people did orchestrate
any sort of attacks on America.
I'm not saying they let,
I'm not saying anything,
but what I am saying is that we know
that they went to war and they said that
there was weapons of mass
destruction when there weren't.
So they're willing to kill some
people that they don't know.
They know.
They know that the very least they're
willing to kill some people that they
don't know in order to
push their own agenda.
We know that
just like when they opened Wall Street,
the toxic air and the thousands
that have gotten sick since then,
my take on it is they
don't know you either,
so you
don't think they would kill you.
Right.
You really think that the p anybody
that would orchestrate death for profit,
you don't think they would kill you.
You really think that they would
because you're a US citizen.
Just the nature of the,
of the team,
the entire and the entire military,
industrial establishment.
I mean this is a killing machines.
Yeah,
wink.
They wouldn't use that in
domestic purposes and not
to mention there's so many
examples of that,
their history that people would
blindly look at where the quorum,
it's just so sad.
That's why it's offensive when someone
says that you're unpatriotic when you see
that and when you see that
and you point that out,
no,
you gotta know that is patriotic.
That is very patriotic because that's
not what we're supposed to be about.
That's not what this country was
supposed to be founded for this,
this country was supposed
to be the best alternative.
This country was supposed to be
the people that got it together.
Say,
listen,
we have to fucking rules,
man.
Here's the rule.
We separate this from that.
We do this,
we do that.
We don't let anybody do this.
You know,
don't give up your liberties.
You have to have essential liberties.
You have to have guns.
Okay?
You gotta protect yourself from enemies,
foreign and domestic.
You know,
it was all set up.
It was all set up.
Sure.
They knew.
We could argue a little
nuances of the founders,
but I understand your point.
That was one thing.
Did you,
did you hear this fucking
dummy Newt Gingrich?
This would be king fat headed clown.
This guy actually said that he believed
that the founding fathers would be much
more aggressive in the way they would
prosecute people for marijuana and that
they would do it probably more violent.
They were growing it themselves.
When they growing it themselves.
It's says in George Washington's fucking
diaries that he was separating the mail
from the female plant.
It's very clear that he says he was
separating the mail from the female plant
for people don't know when
you're growing marijuana,
you've got to separate the mail from the
female plant so that the female grows
the buds and that that
becomes psychedelic.
That's how you make it.
So you'd get high from it.
Right.
So George Washington is essentially
saying he likes to get high,
right.
And he said,
oops,
a little too late.
So he's a fucking stoner.
He separated them too late.
I mean,
what did you have to do back then?
how many different things that you have
going on with George Washington was a
fucking stoner dude?
Almost a hundred percent
God bless for sure.
They grew it.
And by the way,
they grew hemp and they,
they,
you know,
they grew hamping cause they used it
for a lot of things outside of the
psychoactive effects.
They used it for all
sorts of different things.
And there's all these different,
this is all z d different passages.
People smoking on their hemp pipe.
It's written in so many different people's
diaries and George Washington said
that he did mean his slaves
were separating it forum.
Right.
Probably.
But it definitely did.
George have slavery.
You must've had of course.
Right?
They all did.
Yeah.
Right.
So hot right then.
It was,
yeah,
it's a different time,
Brian.
It's a different time.
He was a good man.
Um,
but the,
the point is,
man,
that these,
these fucking people that
are in the positions of,
you know,
wanting to be at the helm of this monster,
it's like,
man,
what a shitbag group of people
we have to choose from getting,
what do you expect?
You know,
I was go back to one of my great heroes,
George Carlin,
and he's like,
garbage in,
garbage out.
Yeah.
What do you expect from this system now
you can argue where these people came
from,
which is where the scam comes in of,
of the entire election.
I mean,
where do
these people come from?
Seriously?
You look at,
he's like,
I don't know.
I don't remember that guy that did.
I don't remember
one Iowa.
They found out that he won.
He beat Mitt Romney,
the crazy religious dude Santorum.
I was.
Right,
right,
right.
Oh,
he's alone.
He's a fucking,
he's a,
uh,
he's a good one.
He's full helm.
Jesus.
He's,
he's Jesus.
Like Leonardo Dicaprio in titanic.
He's at the front of the Jesus
ship with his arms up in the air.
This guy's a,
yeah,
no abortion.
No nothing.
Sue Super Jesus.
He's pushing it hard,
but an amazing group of humans
we have trying to be at the helm.
Michele Bachmann and
a gay husband to this.
If it's really good.
It's a Goddamn Coen brothers movie.
We're living in a Coen brothers
movie and a real good one.
No satirical one at that.
Yeah.
It's a big football game and it's sad to
me to see how you can't watch the news
at that than covering this as though
it's relevant or important to anything.
There's no any decision processes that
these people will have the power to take
hold of will actually accomplish anything
when it's obvious from our last great
hope Obama,
that big business isn't going anywhere.
Yeah,
I,
it doesn't matter who's in Pa,
even Ron Paul,
if he was magically to be swept in with
bulletproof vest on and everything else,
you'll see some dramatic shifts in his
policy the moment he comes in because he
knows,
he knows what's actually possible in that
environment before the shitstorm hits
them from all sides,
all the examples of what
they did to Ralph Nader.
You know with the
prostitution thing on it.
Remember that the car company,
there was a basically a car company set
up Ralph Nader and in a hotel room with
a prostitute and then documented it
cause he was doing all this publicity
against this car company.
How unsafe they're there.
They're cutting costs
on their car production.
He found out very
discreetly how bad it was.
People were dying and they'd try to set
them up and to make them look bad with
this prostitute was incredible.
That's just the tip of the iceberg of
all sorts of games that are played.
You can go straight down the whole
political spectrum and looked at all the
things that seem random,
the wind ski and all these things.
There's a,
there's a subtle orchestration
happening to that.
Not to be conspiratorially oriented,
but that's just the way it is.
You don't mess around.
It's a mafia system.
I want to know where to get casting for
that cause I would love to be a part of
the next one.
You know,
like I'm found in Obama's locker room
and I can't walk and
well they must hire it through craigslist.
I mean at this point in time they can
easily pay someone to just fuck up your
life.
You know,
pay someone like this is
your job be $250,000 your
job is to seduce that guy and
go and get it into his life.
Somehow or another.
They're called PR agencies.
Is that what they do?
Well
can go both sides.
They can be positive towards you or
they can be hired to be completely black
lifts.
Do gonna make you look like shit.
I know that from my own experience of the
weird things that have happened to me,
which I wonder where the roots
of some of these things are.
There's people that blog
and anti psychiatry,
Peter Joseph matters every single day
and follow everything I did like how do
they possibly have time do that
and it makes me think
they're being paid to do it.
Maybe I just know of some companies
that were listed to me that do the exact
same thing to other people and you
don't see them on the forefront.
There are these PR firms
that you can use to,
you've probably seen the ones that you
can go and use to get bad things removed
from your name on the Internet.
I've heard that on the radio
or something like that.
So there's,
there's ones that worked
the other direction.
The more of a black op kind of way.
Yeah,
and they're paid to do so.
Wow.
That's really an
important stars right now.
Really go after porn stars.
There was a,
this one person broke into a word.
They get tested once a month.
I think I might've talked about this
before in broken and still all the records
from all the porn stars and then put
them online and then that shit got taken
down eventually and it found out
it was just this male porn started.
I did it and then now there's like groups
of people that use all those things
that were put online and attack every
single porn start online by putting their
information everywhere.
Oh fuck is with people.
Why would they want to do that?
I don't know.
A few different motivations there.
No,
just so it's a weird thing man
to we're thing that you know,
people want to hurt other people that
badly self appointed guardians of the
status quo that could be labeled a lot.
I picked up a man named jock fresco.
These people that they have,
they're not,
the only thing they have is
their identity preservation.
They will fight tooth and nail to make
sure whatever they believe is held true.
Whether it's political or religious.
I mean I could,
I can't count how many death threats
I got since the first film came out.
Well,
you're quite just
questioning the status quo.
All they're doing is fucking on camera.
Why would somebody want to jet harm?
Well,
because if,
say some deeply religious individuals
sees a porno or catches this sun with it
or something like that,
they feel a huge threat
there for whatever purpose.
You'd be surprised what
motivations people,
that's the root cause.
The root,
the root issue is how fucking dumb
people are and what a giant percentage of
them are just so off the
tracks and in the woods,
misinformed a condition.
How do you turn those folks around?
Cause I think you can't really have this
next level society until you get those
folks to uh,
on track.
Look if that's one of the things
about living in a nice neighborhood.
If you live in a nice neighborhood,
you know,
there's generally a lot
less financial strife.
So people are a little bit more calm.
You know,
it's one of the things that people
don't like about living in neighborhoods
where people are poor.
You know,
there's a lot of tension and
sometimes shit goes down.
Sure.
Well,
you got to get everybody
to the level of no tension,
you know,
in order to have a,
a beautiful society.
How the hell do you do that?
As you pointed out earlier,
you start with the kids,
you make,
uh,
there's,
there's a deeply religious,
uh,
anti structure thing going on in the
world where everyone thinks they can just
keep having kids.
And it doesn't matter what
the resources of the planet,
you know,
it's,
it doesn't matter that no.
Dot.
Don't you dare tell them
how to raise their kids,
forget any kind of instruction.
You know,
that he kids,
people have natural pre-programming.
It's pretty obvious what the men did.
You Watch that guy's
moving forward a whole,
and that's the very beginning.
I was like us moving forward on the
development of kids now it little small
nuances can mess them up
for the rest of their lives.
Whether it's goes to drug addiction,
whether it goes to mental disorders or
even physical disorders and no attention
has been put on there.
If there's anything that I would like
to see put in the public educational
fountain,
it would be how to really
think about your kids,
how important it is,
how the earliest things that happened
to them all fucked them up the rest of
their lives.
If they're not carefully,
carefully collard or carefully
orchestrated Lawan vulnerability.
We're not talking about like holding
kids down and making them do things in a
structured way.
It's allowing the vulnerability of this
natural organism to come to fruition.
A Horse,
for example,
falls right out of the
horse that Boren faltered.
They can walk boom,
humans because of evolution,
they come out way too early.
So the susceptibility of the,
of the,
the infant is so massive
and so misunderstood.
Up until now that people have done things
to their kids that have really fucked
them up for their whole lives at the
infancy stage because of how much
developmental requirements are actually,
they're,
the protections are gone.
So it's a huge topic and there's
a lot of people I could list,
uh,
that can,
that can describe those issues in tax.
The got him gathered.
Mateo has a really good one.
So what is the best case scenario?
It was the best case scenario that the
[inaudible] movement takes place after
some sort of a collapse and we develop
a new society that's based on using of
natural resources universally
and across the board,
and there's no hierarchy
of citizenship and,
and then the people are on the outside.
What do we do?
We fight them off.
Well,
you would want to hope
it's hard to put join.
You'd want to hope that whatever the
cataclysmic may manifest itself to be,
that's pending,
that those on the sidelines,
that barbarians at the gate
as they might have been,
would eventually turn it around to
see the folly of their ways as well.
You know,
it's hard to predict.
It's like I smooth.
It was really a movement
of logic and reason.
It's like,
okay,
here's,
we have,
we have technological automation.
You know what?
People are being replaced by automation.
In fact,
the great driver of
unemployment now is automation.
They won't admit it.
Most economists will not,
a few are coming out now in the medium
that you can go back to the Roosevelt
administration.
They actually wanted to have a stop
on technological invention during the
industrial revolution because of how
fast people were being replaced by
machines.
And that is the core driver of all
unemployment you see in the world today
period.
So what does that mean?
What is the logic say?
Well we can produce more with less.
We don't need people to slave over
some shitty factory job anymore.
We automated no vacations,
higher,
much higher degree of accuracy.
Machines can do things.
There's all sorts of a modular machines
now that can do things like scientific
research,
extremely specific things,
thinking machines,
people like Ray Kurzweil and all this
massive evolution I could ramble on for a
long time.
What does that mean for Human Labor?
Do we keep human labor as a requirement
to live your right to life is to get
income or do you create
a new system that says,
okay,
let's go full forward
with machine automation,
all sectors possible and fill in the
gaps with whomever is willing to do so.
And I think the abundance produced
when enable US society to exist without
people needing money
every minute of the day.
What happens
to all those people that were
working on those assembly jobs?
Well,
they at this stage they wouldn't
know what the fuck to do,
right?
But if you evolve it out,
if you really think about
this for long periods of time,
you get the problem we're going
to have to face eventually.
Well face it now tell until later,
until you see someone in power say,
okay,
we're going to start to
automate and basically do a
form of socialization if you
will,
giving people free food free energy in
order to supplement them for their law,
their lack of purchasing power,
which is what's happening and tell
someone starts to do that in government or
having the workday.
Like,
if Obama was smart and good Bunch
of Roosevelt administration,
they would have put in uh,
a mandate or whatever
you'd want to call it,
where the corporations received some
type of subsidy where they would have the
work day and they would hire twice the
amount of people for that corporation,
giving them the sustenance income.
The that would be,
that would be applicable would
be probably a little bit reduced.
But what else do you do?
They're not going to do that
because the core motivations,
so against it,
corporations responsibilities
to the shareholders.
Shareholders don't want
to see anything like that.
What happens when someone lays a whole
bunch of employees and stock market and
the stock goes up?
Remember it's just sick.
The whole things backwards.
So back to my point and tell automation,
uh,
no one's going to stop automation
cause it's a profit driven thing.
It costs less money to automate
than it does to use people.
And that's what you call the
contradiction of capitalism.
And the words of Karl Marx,
believe it or not,
he recognizes this logo and all you
have is this thing collaging together.
That is unreconcilable.
And tell a new social system
system is put in place,
what do you think is going to
happen with the current system?
How much time do you think we have before?
It's just chaos in the streets and I mean,
it's already chaos and most
of the world in pockets,
I think,
I think 2012 was in,
it'd be prophecy side,
I think 2012 and be a
very interesting year.
It's amazing that things
have accelerated this far,
this close to 2012 when
you look at it from a,
the standpoint,
sure,
everybody thinks well,
it's like the boy who cried wolf.
It's like at a certain point in time like
y two K and this and that and you know
the fucking Pleiades and where's Nibiru?
And at a certain point in time like,
ah,
right,
well you're fucking apocalypse talk,
stop it.
But then as you get closer and
closer to 2012 you're like,
man,
you know,
maybe the Mayans were on assumption.
Well,
I doubt that.
But uh,
what,
what does scare me is
the self feeling shit.
And then people are gonna be jumping out
of windows and shooting things up and
all the ones that have convinced
themselves if some diluted idea,
that's going to be very interesting.
Well,
the other,
oh,
the other thing is like no one is saying
it's going to be the end of the world.
It's just the end of this
calendar could be a new era.
That's awesome.
You know,
it very easily could it,
my personal analysis,
the end of the Mayan calendar
is the end of the age of Pisces.
That's it.
That's the great year.
Starts again with the age of
Aquarius is too hard to predict.
You have like a 1500 to 3000 year buffer.
It's 2020 6,000 year cycle in
the procession of the equinoxes.
And that's what I think it is.
Um,
but whatever,
I don't pay attention to those things,
but as far as,
I don't pay attention to it,
but I do pay attention to the fact that
so many people pay attention to it.
Well,
of course,
you know,
I'm fascinated by astrology.
I don't know if I,
I'm,
I'm a believer in it 100% but I
think it's amazing that they can,
you know,
halfway nailed down personalities and
different traits when they're really good
at it.
And we could argue on that one.
The power of suggestion is a,
is quite phenomenal in the world today.
You'd be amazed.
And then as far as like structuring
questions as far as structuring,
leading people into,
yeah,
I've seen that.
I've seen like psychic stuff,
people do shit like that,
but I'm not even talking about that.
I'm talking about like somebody giving
you a date and some of those real
astrologists they want to know
like what time you were born.
And I don't know if it's real,
but it's amazing that it's
been around so long it,
I do not know if it's real,
but it's amazing that at one point in
time someone actually dedicated enough
time to writing down some sort of a system
to figure out which different things
that are in line when you're
born in the [inaudible].
It's kind of amazing really.
I think it's beautiful.
Beautiful from the standpoint,
a cultural standpoint to find
your place in the universe.
Think other people are doing,
they're looking at the sky,
it looks flat and two d they
think about associations.
They want to feel like
they're connected to it.
The whole definition of God,
and if you go back to my first film,
most natural phenomenon,
stellar cults originated,
merged into the Islam.
Judeo Christian Islamic religion by
symbolism just became his historize
basically.
But you know,
the beauty of it is that people
are trying to relate to something.
That's what I see.
But they still thought the sky was flat,
right?
So the constellations don't even exist.
They don't actually know actually there.
They just looked that way.
You know,
they thought,
who was,
they thought this guy was flat.
Well,
if you look at the sky,
it looks perfectly flat
and the constellations and
the depictions are actually
flat.
That's how they're important.
That's why they have a little
animal things and things like that.
And the Sun rising.
Let's say there's summer solstice,
I believe that's the birth note
or most the spring equinox,
you can't remember.
It's a completely to Di Prima Fascia
is surface flatland view and it doesn't
hold any actual validity because they
had no idea that it was actually the
depth.
You know the depth of the stars and their,
their radiants is so far away,
they're burning out there changing.
There's morphine,
there's expansion.
So you know,
so they just looked at it as like almost
like a picture of flat two dimensional
picture stance is going to fall down.
It's amazing that they did
that for so long though.
They really studied the constellations.
I guess that's a beautiful art form.
It's a beautiful concept
that's outside.
Where's that outside?
Who?
Who,
who's the mother beating?
Nice kid.
Her Kid.
Lovely Pasadena culture.
Well this is the only thing that's the
worst you have to worry about Pasadena.
You know,
this is not like,
you know what's funny
is jungles of Africa.
I know this girl that I was a stripper
a long time ago and she found out about
you from the green room of a strip club.
There was a hairdryer
hair designer that was,
he was a gay guy that was
in love with your shit.
And so he used to tag you throughout San
Francisco and in this green room of a
strip club,
your,
your tag is all over.
He just tagged the fuck
out of this green room.
That's how she found out about it.
And then she got so moved by your movie
that she started posting flyers around
San Francisco,
uh,
to promote your movie because
she was so moved by her.
That
was what it was so phenomenal on the,
uh,
the original owner.
It still persists to this day on its own.
I did know publicity
for any of these things.
It's always been self driven.
It somehow,
it seemed to tap into some element of
people that they appreciate it and felt
the need to re communicate
to other people,
which is inadvertent to me.
I certainly didn't anticipate that,
but yeah,
it was,
it blown your mind.
Well,
I get these,
I get these marketing calls occasionally
or emails from these marketing jackass
is like,
how did you do that?
What kind of,
what kind of algorithms are
you using in your viral media?
Like it's just word of mouth,
man.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Highly envy.
The film series is a highly
envied by a lot of people.
They're trying to,
there's a lot of films trying to duplicate
the idea to duplicate the concept and
build kind of a farce community out of it.
And the same way that was
natural to the movement.
So,
but anyway,
what do you expect?
It's amazing.
Everyone assumes dollar signs and
there's a lot of people around.
Yeah,
of course.
Well there's um,
there's always been someone at the helm
of something at different points in
time,
you know,
different cultures,
different religions,
different,
you know,
different kingdoms has always
been someone with a new idea.
And I think everybody's sort of recognizes
that this thing is falling apart.
No one's buying anymore.
And a new things going to come along,
man.
And we've got to jump on it.
We're going to jump on it because this is,
this really is the future because this,
this dying animal that you see this,
this fucking elephant and
donkey system is stupid.
It's stupid.
And everybody recognizes
it's destroying us.
Just look around.
It's destroying the fabric of almost
everything that you see around you.
You have every life
support systems in decline.
Our psychology is really fucked up.
And if he's taken a look around
what coach was doing today,
I mean the public health
issue is bad enough.
I'm just waiting for
the tipping point where,
where uh,
the lifespan starts to tip cause I
think it's just a matter of time.
I have a friend that has a 10 year old
and she has her 10 year is in school and
uh,
you know,
he's an active kid and the
psychologist or psychiatrist,
I guess it would be for school,
is trying to give the
kid trucks and he says,
well he's a good kid.
He's not,
he's not a,
he just gets bored in class and he acts
up a little bit but he doesn't need to
be drugged.
And she goes,
you're so easy.
You're so quick to drug them.
Like how many kids in his classes are,
are,
are on drugs.
And he says,
well I am not an liberty to give
that it's confidential information,
but let me tell you it's
somewhere near half.
So I don't know why the
fuck he would say that.
He's not at liberty.
So,
and then she goes,
wait a minute,
a half,
half.
Do you know you think half of the kids
in school have a mental problem to the
point where they need drugs?
Wow,
that's amazing.
That is amazing that there's someone
out there that is a professional that's
able to do something like that.
Now this is a woman
telling me about her child.
I do not know for numbers were correct.
You know,
I mean she,
she might've just,
I don't see she's adding
marijuana on a dummy though.
She's not a dummy,
you know?
And she was,
she was telling me this and it made a
whole lot of sense to me and I was like,
that is amazing that they're just,
they're so willing to drug
people and that's a of sickness.
Absolutely.
I mean,
it's fucking sucks.
Okay.
There's a reason why
you kids moving around.
He's healthy.
He's healthy as brainworks great creative.
Yeah.
He's,
and he's getting all this input that
blows and he knows he can get out of that
class and play video games and
have laughs with his friends and,
and say hi to girls.
And that would be awesome,
but right now this sucks and it just,
I can't take the suck any longer.
It's like,
it's like you're telling me that the
only way to learn is to be board into a
fucking coma and just accept this really
low frequency of memorizing shit that
some other asshole
figured out and so that's,
that's,
that's it.
That's what school is every day.
Just pounding it into you that the only
way to get through this is you're going
to have to hate it when
meanwhile everything else you
get good at every game you
get good at,
you get good at because you love it.
You know,
and get good at video
games because they're fun.
When you get to be a bad asset,
a video game,
it's because that video games.
Awesome.
Why do you guys get good at basketball?
Because it's fun to be good at basketball.
When you hit that three pointer,
it's fucking fun.
Everything else that you get good at,
it's fun except the shit that
you have to deal with in school.
Unmotivated people,
they're underpaid and you want to talk
about like the symptom of a sick society.
The fact that we put so
little emphasis on schools,
so little emphasis on teaching.
It should be an honor
fields from the plant to let
guard over people's children.
Man,
you should be the most honorable,
respectable people available.
Super Intelligent and super well paid.
We should be paying
teachers fuckloads of money,
man.
You know,
they should be,
it should be like a prestigious position.
It should be something that
you like really aspire to
instead of something where
it's a passion,
but you're getting fucked by the system.
We,
you barely have enough money to eat.
You know,
you look at how much a teacher
makes in a public school system,
it's it fucking deplorable.
It's amazing that it's accepted.
It's like for whatever reason,
we don't step out of boundaries and,
and look at it objectively and go,
we've got some core problems and a big
part of it is our children and they
developed to become shitty fucking human
beings against their own intentions.
It's not like they want to suck out.
The kids don't want to suck his,
his are just balls of potential
victims.
The victims of a system
that really doesn't care.
It doesn't understand,
doesn't put any resources towards it.
It's like you have so much money to go
to war and you have so little to go to
school.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
It's amazing that you've worked
out the numbers that way.
What level of a imposition you
can have is to go to college,
get $80,000 worth of
debt and then guess what?
You ripe to be enslaved and
some hideous corporate estate
you just hoping you can
afford a Lexus next year.
You know,
every day just live in a slave.
But back to the drug issue just
preps kids now so they can,
when they get to be adults and try to
figure out why they're so miserable,
why they hate their job,
while they have no
contribution to society,
why they don't have any
artistic energy anymore.
Well that's perfect cause then you can
give them the PROZAC and give them all
the other drugs that will nullify them
to make them adhere to this process.
Yeah.
Poor little guys.
So if you analyze all that
and use statistical view,
public health from a psychological
and mental health standpoint,
you look at depression rates,
you look at everything.
Then you look at the environmental
problems you look at,
you just go straight down the spectrum
of public health to physical health too,
to environmental health.
You have one massive drop off.
It's ridiculous,
and that's,
that's the data idea with far too often,
and that's why I think the system
can hold up for that much longer.
I mean,
the cancer rates are
out of control for one.
As a general rule,
there's more cancer occurring
now than ever before.
There's too many of us.
Well,
no,
it's not too many of us know.
Nope.
I don't agree with that at all.
That's,
that's some people intuitively speaking,
you'd want to say that.
I think the board can hold many,
many more times the number of people
if it was properly structured,
but we have to also deal with something
different as far as like fuel,
right?
We can't be,
we can't be a carbon
fossil fuel base.
Not Great.
Paradigm shift is we've been
living off of fossil deposits,
which is one of those
ignorant things possible.
Since we're surrounded by the
movement of energy from the Sun,
new everything else,
we have these,
uh,
we've,
there's no crisis in the energy.
There's no energy problem.
There's only the crisis of
ignorance as I stated before.
And that's really the big thing.
We have plenty of energy.
So you think,
um,
uh,
ideally,
especially in southern California,
we should have like solar domes,
right?
It should be like,
should be solar.
They're there.
Well you should.
Well,
if you really want to hear it too,
it,
you should hovering in the sky,
all solar,
you just go with it.
You go local,
you take this block which has plenty of
sun exposure and you apply for the forte
paints and high,
high quality advancements and does not,
it does very little money
going into the research.
By the way.
It's hard to get any kind
of funding for those things.
So if you imagine how fast we could
advance with these renewable mediums
localized,
if we actually put the energy into them,
you can do the extrapolation on how
far we'd become cause technology just
continues to move beyond our expectations.
Don't you need batteries though?
For Solar?
Between super capacitors and and hydrogen,
which is the new idea.
You could store it at these things for
easily overcome the intermittency of
solar easily through battery technology.
The problem with battery technology,
again,
in the market system,
you want constant turnover.
You want scarcity,
you want people to go back and buy
more batteries because that's what this
entire system and also the
problem minerals to create
the batteries like lithium
ion and they get to go for hydrogen.
But uh,
now I think hydrogen batteries
or hydrogen storage storage.
So this would not be a solar
issue then because you can't,
usually you bring the solar into it,
you bring solar power and then
you convert that into hydrogen.
Somehow it's stored.
It's stored in the water,
stored in the hydrogen.
How's that?
That's a new technology
that's been internal.
So no need for batteries,
no needs for better my on nothing,
no need for the minerals
that they get in the car.
You might have to have some lithium ion
in intermittent sense dependent on how
the battery is constructed
or but super capacitors,
which is another concept
which isn't utilized.
You know how you like your
computer as capacitors,
that store energy,
a very different technology
than the standard battery,
which is kind of like a,
you fill it in there.
There's many different forms and there's
a great deal of advancement there and
there's really nothing that I can
find that would inhibit storage for an
admitted NSI from solar.
If you really put your mind to it.
There's to say that would
take some more deep analysis,
but I can't imagine we'd run
out of minerals just for that.
Well,
it's just,
it's always been ironic to me that the,
the,
the chain from minerals coming out
of the ground to the super advanced
technology,
just such a barbaric chain,
and they look down at the people
in no shoes with pick axes,
pulling the minerals out of the ground,
the Congo and how that eventually
gets to your apple laptop.
I was like,
wow.
It's pretty fascinating that,
that that is all,
I mean that that's a part of the equation.
The part of the equation
for high technology,
whether it's solar power,
anything is you need the
minerals from Africa of course,
and that's how they're
extracting those fucking things
and tell him.
Molecular engineering comes into play
and we've begin to synthesize these,
these raw materials from scratch
through molecular engineering,
which is around the corner probably
within the next 50 60 years.
It's already small advancements in that.
See,
the more you just liked,
that's alchemy.
It is kind of kind of,
yeah,
sure.
That's what people had predicted.
Well,
you remember probably
the old many years ago,
it was one of the companies,
they spelled their name and little Adams
and they showed it in the magnifying
glass at big feet.
We've come a long way since then and
there's a lot of great futurist ideas out
there that can basically
create replicators for your
home where you're not going
to be like me going to
a store to buy anything.
You're going to be creating
these things in your home.
And if there's anything that will
destroy the market system quite rapidly,
it will be advancements like that.
How do you possibly maintain labor systems
where you can synthesize a laptop in
one swoop,
download the model from your computer,
it goes into this vat,
it's in this,
this dust,
and then the Milan molecular element
is released just like you print into a
printer or three d printing,
which I had in my feel moving forward
as a primitive notion of that they can
print for cars now in one swoop.
There's so much advanced technology out
there that is not known that would solve
so many problems.
Uh,
it's frustrating.
It's very frustrating.
And the very fact that these efficiencies
are there and not being pushed as fast
as they should be,
as even more frustrating.
But you see why?
Why?
Because efficiency is the
enemy of everything that
turns a profit that we want.
We want to serve this everything.
We don't want to solve problems.
We want people with cancer not
to cure the cancer we want.
That's an ethic though
that they think about that.
No,
it's subconscious.
It's syntax of thought.
They don't necessarily think that way.
Just like guys sitting around a room and
the Pentagon start to justify killing
3000 people.
They're not thinking in terms of
being murderers or anything else.
They're thinking in terms of business.
So you know,
if you,
if you want to make a laptop and
you want people to buy it again,
that things die probably three years
from the time you buy it in different
component problems that will go on.
It doesn't mean it has to know,
but the turnover is so important.
Efficient efficiency is
the driver of this system,
which is why we had
the pollution problems,
the waste problems and
the health problems.
And why did they feed in together and
while you are whole GDP is literally
driven by sickness and
inefficiency and waste.
That's the,
if there's anything that blows my mind,
it's how anti economic,
our current system
really is on all levels.
So if you want to solve problems,
you want to make a car
that lasts 60 years,
that's easily interchangeable.
That can be,
excuse me,
more than that.
Bailey a hundred years,
easily interchangeable.
They can be updated.
You want to make a smart phone that
has the longest lasting components.
They don't need to throw away.
These things could be done
if we wanted to do it,
but the be the be an enema to what the
market system requires for constant
turnover,
constant turnover,
constant money.
Circulation means more jobs.
So it's planned obsolescence you think?
Is this like a business model?
It's planned and intrinsic.
Another level level is in
transactions that people,
you know,
they build things the best
they can and they don't last.
They just break two levels to it.
Planned obsolescence is very real.
You can go into historical archives
of car companies to know that they
strategize.
I can guarantee you the people behind
apple sit there and their rooms and they
had full on statistics
kind of operating systems.
Oh you have an operating
system update the software,
the software scan is even worse cause
that's just numb ones and Zeros.
The fact that they even charge over
and over for that more hilarious.
That's planned obsolescence.
Intrinsic obsolescence is even more
fucked up if you think about it.
That computer for it to be built has to
go through the engine of the industrial
profit complex,
which means all the components,
the extraction,
everything else someone's taking off
the top throughout the entire thing.
Right.
And there's cost
efficiency at the very end.
So if you're apple computer,
you bought a by the components
to make your computer.
You can't buy necessarily the highest
grade level stuff in order to remain
competitive against the other people
that are selling computers similar like
windows or whatever.
So you have to constantly be a little
bit behind in order to be competitive so
you can drop the price.
But there was,
the quality of the product has
to be diminished immediately
for people to afford
it.
The equation of,
of cost efficiency refuses to allow the
best possible goods to be produced at
any one time period.
It's a rule.
It's a natural evolution,
natural and natural dynamic,
if you will,
of what it means to save
money and to make profit.
So everything's a piece of
shit the moment it's produced.
Yeah.
Well that's separate.
The shit like Ferrari's.
Even a Ferrari though.
Think about the price of a Ferrari though.
That's why it's so expensive part.
I mean they really make
the best shit they can,
but it's not really the best.
Oh fuck yeah,
it is four or five,
eight Italia.
Have you seen that thing?
Twin clutch gearbox,
ridiculously powered VA mid engine.
Supercar come on man.
That's about as good as human
beings have ever created.
It really is.
It's,
it's the,
the peak of engineering,
the there,
you know,
they use race car driving to,
to,
to engineer their cars.
They push cars to the limit and every
year they go around the Newburg ring like
a couple of seconds faster and everybody's
like straining for like the new
Porsche is a seven minutes and 40 seconds.
The new nine 11 and that's
like this is an electric,
no,
it's not electric,
but they have,
they have cars that they
have developed that are electric.
Porsche has a,
they had a um,
a gt three cup car that they raced
in the 24 hour race that was a,
that was an electric car.
They're definitely trying to come
up with electrical technology,
but they're are making the
best cars they can make.
Well,
let's define,
get to like there's certain things
that are being done right now.
They're at the peak of production.
Even though they are being produced,
they're essentially making like some
high end shit that's the best they can
make.
We could probably argue that one
because if you look at all the advanced
propulsion technology that's used in NASA,
why aren't they applying
such things like that?
You can try to thought not exactly,
but there are all sorts of things that
could be that are probably more advanced
than either of us,
either of us know that could be applied
to that Ferrari but they're not because
I actually sense of therefore
no one will be able to anyway
gas that you could get a pump either
you have to work within no skin strains
cause our gas is actually
really low compared to a,
like our octane's late [inaudible]
91 in other parts of the country.
I know you can get like 93 or four.
Sure.
So I guess it's bad to have more octane.
But you see my point though,
you can't make something
really that people can buy it.
But I see what you're saying.
Demograph heart.
It's demographic targeted too.
So what's the majority,
what are the majority of people?
Majority of people are
lower and middle class.
You make shit that doesn't work very
well so they can afford it and invariably
it breaks and they suffer
in the end because they have
to deal with the constant
cyclical turnover and the need to
constantly repair and everything else.
When everything hits the fan
and you start your calls,
what,
what will everyone do for a job?
How does everyone get?
You'll be doing my laundry.
I'll be doing your laundry.
I'm not good at laundry done and you're
not going to want me to do your laundry,
right?
Um,
what did she do?
What does everybody get a job?
I mean,
what does it become?
Communism.
I mean,
how do you figure out what
the fuck everybody does to
contribute to this thing?
What if you,
you know what if you're a lazy cunt,
how do we deal with Lacey,
consonant
number,
that lazy concert victims of culture,
right?
And you know,
that's,
that's the threshold here is where
do we take them on mushroom trips and
straighten them out who we do?
Well,
think about it this way.
If you had a kid go into a store and they,
there's a kid in his mother and the kid,
it's today and the kid goes and grabs
some stuff and shoves it in his pockets.
The mom says,
no,
that's stealing slaps the kid's hand.
The kid learns a valuable lesson
in his values are altered,
right?
Think about the same type of
idea where we go into a store,
there's no money.
It's not even a store.
It's a,
it's a supply house.
And a kid goes in and grabs whole
handfuls of shit that is completely
unnecessary because
there's no utility for it.
And the mother says,
no,
that's not what we do because
we don't need all of that.
It has to be there and we'll come back
and get it later as we need it because
the systems that efficient.
So you see how the value
programming is very easy to adapt.
So throughout time you'd begin
to change people's values,
how they relate to their environment.
Imagine if you didn't
have to worry about money,
Joe,
imagine the extent that you could pursue
in your life the interest that you
found interesting.
And invariably I guarantee you,
if you look
at how people respond,
especially in their later years
when they get more introspective,
everyone wants to feel like
they're contributing to society.
Everyone wants to feel like
they've done something social,
so that kind of greed,
self absorbed share,
that's a very adolescent immature thing
and it's probably there to a certain
effect and the evolution of the
adaptation of the human being as he grows.
But if you have a system doesn't
support or reinforce those issues,
the then the miserable cock suckers and
dimwits and assholes and jerk off small
won't materialize.
They need,
but they're here.
We need to figure out how to get rid of
them either to get rid of him or to fix
them and bring them up.
That's going to be very difficult
because that's a real issue.
It's a real,
it's super real issue at
the core of everything.
It's an educational problems.
Why Doug?
Stan Hope,
how to stop doing as
parties in the desert.
It is what it is.
I didn't hear Doug,
Doug,
Stan hope,
my buddy and a hilarious comedian used
to have these parties in the desert.
But you would have like,
you know,
anybody could come and
everybody knew about it online.
So you would have like a thousand really
cool people and to just unbearable
Douche.
Sure.
And the too unbearable
douchebags would make the,
make the whole party useless.
And those guys need to be,
you have new,
you have to figure out
what to do with them.
They,
there's some people out there
that are off fucking mess,
not an issue of having
this beautiful solar dome.
Where y'all all this hippie pussy inside.
Just line it up for you.
We're still going to have to deal
with the barbarians at the gates cause
otherwise they liked the,
like the New Orleans,
it's stormed Egypt and
took over the pyramids.
They're going to come
in and rush this bitch.
Well I don't,
I don't see this materializing
in some isolated place,
uh,
where the barbarians are
waiting on the sidelines to uh,
there,
there are people.
Yeah,
the power went out.
Right now there'd be hordes
of our bearings on the
street with hockey sticks and
guns and whatever the fuck they could
look at whatever the fuck you had.
And that would last for
a little while until,
until someone said,
yeah,
you don't have to do that if
we just calm down a moment.
So the transition can happen.
Even with the people that we have now
that seem to be the creme de la creme,
the victims of this culture,
it just going to take
a great deal of care.
And I think as a natural consequences,
the system fails.
There'll be a great number of people that
will turn around faster than you would
believe.
Once their needs are
pulled away from them,
they realized that their needs have to
come from some other process or somewhere
else.
Then the adaptation becomes natural.
Well,
one of the things about the occupy Wall
Street movement that's fascinated me is
the idea that all these
people sort of lived together.
You know,
they don't,
they're not just,
you know,
protesting together.
They have fucking tents and
they have a community there.
They have books you could like go to
their little library and read their books.
They have,
I'm all set up there,
you know that's so,
I mean it's essentially right now it's
not really a commune but it's on its way
and they could easily,
it's one of those guys said,
listen man,
my car,
my cousin has a hundred acres out in
the wilderness and they have fruit trees
and they have the grow vegetables and
it's animals and we can hide and we can
make a fucking culture.
Let's do this.
As long as we don't show any
aggression towards the government.
Certainly been done before,
but then they shut you down and they go
Waco on your ass and fucking toys the
building.
Or if you're a whole nother country,
like the attempts of the Bolshevik
revolution of some something new,
despite what anyone ever
thought of communism,
that was quickly shut down as a
concept by the western powers.
You gotta be totally nonthreatening.
If you want to start this cult,
we have to like get a
nice piece of property,
but it's got to be real pretty
and there's no property.
This isn't a,
this is an evolution of ideas.
We're not going to,
we're not going to set up any shit on me,
man.
You're going to need a car,
a camp.
Can they get an EAD camp,
Peter?
Right.
Come on man.
Right,
right outside of Arizona and my Jim,
Jim Jones glasses.
You don't need glasses,
dude.
You're going to be fine.
You're really good at this.
You can make it back to
these people and just,
and just run the whole big solar dome
right there from a Sonoma Sonoma's a good
spot.
They're prepared.
They're accepting it.
They're ready.
They've got the crystals out
there ready to take the vitamin.
Yeah.
Led is going to happen,
man.
Do you,
you think that,
um,
we're going to have a situation where
money is going to lose all of its value,
um,
where it's going to be so bad and the
economy's going to get bankrupts so
inextricably that we're going to be
stuck in a situation where we're like,
like Russia was at one
point in time or you know,
where they were waiting on line with
bales of money to buy a loaf of bread.
Well,
you're already do you see
in the military realization of the police,
you're already seeing the
social destabilization
spread because of the faulty
economic premise that is creating the
unemployment that is creating the debt
crisis that will invariably highly be
very inhibited by the energy crisis if
massive moves aren't met.
So the three issues,
as I mentioned before,
is the unemployment crisis.
And I can expand on that.
Let's think about this for a second.
If you have technology
replacing human labor,
which is emitted across the board
now mostly by colonists as opposed to
economist,
because economists market economists are
an extreme denial on this one and many
a debate.
You replace people,
but you're not just replacing their job
to replacing their ability to purchase
other stuff and circulate the
economy and that that's even worse.
And it,
it's farthest extension.
That means that the entire fuel of
growth is being slowly shut down,
which means that the system
will lose more and more,
and the system will eventually just
stifled to a point that it can't operate
anymore apart from common or medial
jobs or problems that might arise.
But there's no way you're
going to continue employing
people on this planet and
numbers that we have in the past.
It's all downhill from here because the
profit motivation to replace people by
machines is inherent to
the interest to save money.
Mcdonald's has had systems on the shelf
for 20 years now that would replace
everyone in their kitchen.
Now they are the front
kiosk systems as well.
They don't do it only because they're
corporate view is to be social and as an
employer they have a stake in that.
Even though it's built the contrary
to logic and if you look carefully,
they are automating very,
very slowly.
Just like all the grocery
stores are automating,
you're reducing purchasing power and
there's no way this system's going to
maintain itself.
Once that continues and accelerates,
it's the contradiction of capitalism,
so the idea of human labor
is becoming obsolete.
That in its own right is going to
inspire some serious reflection and some
massive upheavals.
It's going to be
calling everybody contribute.
Is it possible that everybody can find
their own unique way to contribute
outside of manufacturing things outside
of working menial jobs outside of fast
food supermarkets,
retail,
when you remember that,
uh,
it's a lot of jobs.
Consumption is twice what it was
now than it was in World War II.
Advertising as completely
fucking per capita,
twice per person,
per person.
The average person's in America,
since World War Two consumes
twice the amount of shit,
which obviously means something's askew.
Why?
Why is that?
Why do we feel the need to have
all this other excess stuff?
Socially speaking?
If you go to a small tribes that aren't,
don't have access to television,
they're very,
very happy with it,
very minimalistic life.
They don't,
their happiness isn't contingent upon
how they compare themselves to others or
any type of notion of
value that they live in,
the culture that's been manifest
within the resources around them.
And they happier than any American
with the multimillion dollar house and
everything else,
which is usually an antidepressants.
So we have as a neuroses
that's been built,
which is fueling all of this industry
that's completely irrelevant basically.
And the more that happens,
the more we try to invent new jobs.
You know,
I had one guy,
economist tell me that,
oh,
we're just going to end
up using Facebook money.
Say we'll have everybody on the Internet
doing something with Facebook or some
other network was somehow they gain
credits and they'll use those credits as
currency now.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Something,
I dunno know,
I was talking about this like a year ago.
Remember this,
just remember Joe,
we talked about where the future's
going to be post with your buddy.
And my point is it wouldn't surprise me
if we reached that point where you have
a whole group of these freaks like
straight out like idiocracy or something
where they're all doing the most
relevant actions are relevant.
Waste of life,
waste of the human brain does nothing
to contribute just to maintain the,
the idea of employment.
So I don't think that's going to happen.
I think it's going to self destruct.
Once the energy crisis
hits and the debt crisis,
which continues to strangle
hold the entire planet,
these three things will combine.
I can't predict the future,
but I think within a couple of
years you're going to see some very,
very radical shifts in a lot
of governments on this planet.
I think a lot of detachment will occur.
You're going to see an
extension of military invasions.
They got out of a rock,
they're going to go into a raw and they
gotta get their energy resources there.
They've got a secure in the Middle East
for other resources as far as minerals
and gold and other things
that are there too.
There's a,
there's a,
the faster collapses,
the more criminal the meltdown becomes
and that's something too I think people
should pay attention to and
we haven't even seen shit yet.
Now that we have time holes.
By the way,
Joe,
did you see that Pentagon
created some time
and now they can make it Vince disappear?
Well No.
First of all you're dealing with like
a nanoseconds you're dealing with right
now.
This is version one
and this is only what they're
telling us about they they,
they could have been having
these time holes for some time.
I think so because essentially the
Pentagon is using guys that are at the
forefront of science and the
forefront of science is pretty,
it's published.
It's pretty much out there.
Everybody knows pretty much
what everybody is working on.
I mean not,
and they mean there are,
there's some definitely
some black op projects,
but uh,
you know,
these guys is that there's not a whole
lot of these dudes and the way they stay
at this level of,
you know,
of being a bad superintelligent
motherfucker have to exchange information.
How far,
how long is it?
Just a few seconds.
Like some athletic my
nipple and I'd be like,
who did this?
No,
you wouldn't even believe
receive it.
There's no way you'd
be able to perceive it.
But the idea is that this is
just one full 40 pico seconds.
That's what it is.
It's what it's,
the research is admit there's a big
difference between human hiding.
Laser means 40 picoseconds and
hiding military operations.
Lasting minutes or even several seconds.
But the idea is that they've,
they've started it.
Wow.
Yeah.
They started some interesting,
exciting.
That is really exciting.
You know what,
man,
it's,
it isn't.
It isn't.
I mean everything is military.
It's the Pentagon is the one
that fucking came up with this.
That's the most incredible thing.
Like when you look at our
capacity for innovation,
they're the really impressive shit
is all the stuff that blows things.
The fuck up course.
You know,
look,
cell phone cameras are really impressive.
It's really impressive that you can make
a little video and make a movie from
your phone.
You know?
It's way more impressive.
You drop a little box out of
a plane and a city evaporates.
That's incredible.
You know?
And what is that?
That's just,
that's,
you know,
that's the peak of our technology,
the peak of our technology and it's the
most impressive as a fucking laser beam
to cut the earth and half.
You know,
if there's any,
any better proxy,
I'm not quite sure what is,
you know,
if you look at how much energy and
ingenuity is going into these things,
what if we apply that
idea to feeding people?
What if we apply that idea
to doing actually relevant
the hard nose folks that
occasionally I agree with.
Would say,
we know what these fucks.
They don't feed themselves.
This is evolution out there.
They're supposed to be figuring it out.
It was supposed to be getting it together,
which I don't.
I don't a hundred percent agree with it.
They should pick like a year or something
where like the whole year they're
like,
all right,
every scientist you're this year,
it's cancer.
You have one year and just every single
scientist like devote on something
because scientists have particular
fields that they're scientists.
Yeah,
but you're all scientists see scientisty
nuclear physicists to go after aids.
Well,
if you think of another example
system so inhibiting through
its competitive mechanisms
that the Prima Fascia
Association,
the assumption is that basically everyone
competing amongst themselves within
the same sector will
produce better results,
but that's cognitive leap erroneous.
You want to get people
together to share their ideas,
not get proprietary.
You want to do it actually,
if what?
They really have the interest to cure or
solve a problem or create something of
the highest efficiency or utility,
there's no better way to do that than
to get them with that creative drive.
In one setting.
So you take all the cell phone companies,
put them together,
diminish them into one holding company
for all of humanity that produced the
best goddamn cell
phone.
Right?
You could do that for anything and I'm
sure if we actually thought about that
cancer would be be cure.
Well it was actually cancer
cures out there already,
but cancer as we note in the establishment
would have been cured a long,
long time ago.
There's way too much money being made
through this competitive practice though,
and of course the allegation of cancer
and that goes back to the inefficient
inefficiency mechanisms.
What drives it all?
If I could give you the wheel,
if I could give you the wheel,
this great,
great world,
this great society,
there's one,
one giant global culture,
what would you do?
What would your first move if we Peter,
Peter,
Joseph,
just throw in one the electrons.
It's the wrong logic.
Doug is as well.
There wouldn't be any elections.
There's no greater high insulin online
poll you want and you get to be king.
I would,
there wouldn't be a place for that.
How do you mind?
Tague was a close second.
You would,
she didn't get as much pokes,
which is fortunately it
is when he pokes his you,
but you know there's like ice
move and prevailed and you're,
you're in charge of putting
this thing together.
You don't want to be right.
You want it all to like
figure it out itself.
No one single person.
It's the greatest insult to fucking have
like a president of the United States.
What do we in the dynasty and yes,
we still are monk primitive Lynita
we need an Alpha and Alpha month.
It's apparently it is culturally.
We're just still still monkeys,
but we can percent chimpanzee
or whatever we are.
We can adapt pretty quickly that we have
that cerebral cortex that popped out
that can override all
those lower brain reacts,
butterfly along his wig.
Gated.
We grow up.
Well,
we're,
we're taught how to squash our instincts.
Those stupid instincts are still there.
The instincts dominate
the instincts to Gel,
be jealous,
the instincts to want to fuck other dudes,
girlfriends,
those instincts or our primal,
you know,
they're all in there.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe not though every,
every film,
every film you see out there
reinforces such things like that.
It's hard to say just
even elm reinforces it,
but also does every you,
your instincts,
your own nature.
You know,
we are clearly some sort of an
animal and conscious being hybrid,
you know,
and we,
we battle with these very primitive,
I mean you ever be in front of somebody
and you just want to punch them in the
fucking head.
Well,
if you are a champion,
you were living in the jungle,
that's what you would do,
would just punch him in the head.
That chimp is pissing you off.
He just bite it,
you know?
I mean,
that's what they do.
That's what we have this thing going on
in our head where we're trying to squash
all that nonsense.
Just their poop on him,
on him.
You're a Bonobo.
That's why I'm much more,
a much more peaceful.
It's right.
Most of their fights with
carrying around sticks.
So they do,
whoever picks up the biggest stick,
it's like,
oh,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Look at that stick.
Right.
You know,
they don't actually like go to blows
like the regular chimpanzees fuck each
other out.
They kill each other,
but Benobos really,
they're mostly solve
their issues through sex.
Is that you?
Yeah.
How do you saw your boob on you?
Okay.
There's no universal,
there's no universal is no king.
I know what you're saying and I know
you're very sensitive about this because
that is that what happens
in every situation where one
person gets an inordinate
amount of attention.
I'm sure you're getting
and you're very charismatic dude.
You're very intelligent,
you're very well spoken.
There must be some sort of a push in one
sense or another to get you to kind of
lead things,
right?
I mean,
you must feel,
well that's why I'm here.
I'm just trying to
communicate these ideas.
Do you feel responsible?
Does it mean you've created a movement,
right?
I mean essentially you press
the button movement created,
it's created south,
but you did press start,
press start.
But then again,
you know,
in a sense of cause Audi,
who of us really trigger anything?
I could go back and take the
Zeit geist film and I could say,
well this is an influence
of all these other people.
I can say Bill Hicks and
George Carlin needs like guys,
you know,
this is the values just spread.
It was like a,
there's an evolution and the organism
of knowledge that we really hold on to.
But you are part of it as well.
No,
I understand.
I know you're being humble
and understand your point.
If you didn't create that video,
we wouldn't be having this conversation.
You wouldn't have had this movement,
you wouldn't have.
So you've charged up a lot of
people's brains with that man.
And it was uh,
there's been a lot of
inspiration out there,
which has come from many
different directions.
So I had an issue with the nine 11 stuff
that when you guys did the first video,
it essentially,
you were saying that nine 11 was an
inside job and then you knew that the
buildings could not have
come down any other way.
Right.
Isn't that something that was
said with creative license?
Yeah.
That's what was definitely implies to
for for a fact because it was your,
this was the you,
you did not anticipate this ever being
what it was and you were just trying to
get an effect on the assumption that the
audience would of course make up their
own mind because before that there's a
great deal of evidence and the opinion of
the creator.
Then all probabilities moving forward.
Yeah.
That statement was made declaratory.
You think that when you see
like tower one tower two,
do you think that they were detonated
Taiwan and tell her to most probably where
it's all x,
Y and Z's.
To me we'll trade center
seven by all means,
the World Trade Center seven is the
only one that when you look at it,
it fell into its foundation,
which is exactly what happens.
Even beyond that eye witness testimony
of people that were stepping over bodies
from pre weakening
explosions that were there.
You have all sorts of things that do
not add up seismic elements that were
brought into play.
Mostly no one died and tower seven no,
there was a whole sea of people.
There was one of the guy
that that mysteriously died,
I believe of some illness.
His name was,
um,
it was a black man.
What class?
It was like,
oh I know what you're talking about.
He was the guy who said
that he saw bodies.
One other person were in the elevators
that blew out and the eighth floor and he
basically,
he was the only eyewitness
testimony to that in the lobby.
And he actually worked for the mayor too,
which was even more interesting.
Well that one certainly looks like
a demolition w the way it fell.
But the other,
the other towers,
I've never seen a controlled demolition
where it starts from the top and sort of
pancakes down like that.
It usually falls into itself.
You know it too.
Did you do,
do it goes,
it goes and collapse into the space.
I mean,
I don't know.
Maybe there's another way to do it.
Maybe they can do it
where it pancakes down,
but it also couldn't,
it isn't it possible that
a structural failure,
cause they were hit by
giant jet jet engines,
jet planes,
not since they were awesome.
They were designed to take the
impact of some faulty engineering,
like they thought it was the
idea that we were having,
they were wrong.
A cold structure,
law of conservation of momentum.
You have a cold structure
down here regardless of how
hot it is up here to see a
systemic collapse.
If you look at the NIST
studies and everything else,
which didn't even explain
the collapse by the way,
it's beyond in probable.
And I've yet to meet one structural
engineer that could ever explain that,
especially given the free
nature of it when it hit,
not to mention all the
other characteristics,
fallen nature,
meaning it fell a very
similar to free fall speed,
very close to free fall speed.
Of course,
not to mention the pre
weakened in explosions,
the subbasement explosions,
the recipe of it was perfectly in
order with everything that you'd see in
controlled demolition except this was
just extremely advanced and it's an
implosion instead of an explosion.
Um,
I've had this conversation with several
people who believe his exact same thing
and one of them was Michael
[inaudible] who's on last week.
And,
um,
I always ask the same question,
how many people,
how many people know about this?
If you believe that that is the case and
you believe that it was some sort of an
inside job coordinating explosions,
well,
if you were an engineer that could,
to have access to the elevator shafts,
which would have led you to all the
pivotal structural beams that would be
required to do this,
you could probably do it over the
course of time with 15 people,
15 people,
and then we'll shoot them all.
I've no idea if those words think about
how long did it take for people to come
out about the Kennedy assassination.
How long did it take for,
you know,
all these other events that have occurred
that people had been tight lipped
about for so,
so long thing about any historical
event of black operation.
There's,
it's a tight club in that world.
Tight,
tight club.
It doesn't,
it doesn't surprise me at all
that no one would come forward.
My God,
no one would come forward.
And they would set up explosions and
bring down two gigantic skyscrapers.
Why the world watched.
And none of those assholes
wanting to claim credit for that.
No one wants to step up and say they
had something to do with that based on
historical precedent.
Precedent doesn't surprise me at all.
Just go back and look at all
the history of black operations,
CIA and FBI.
Look at the names that were under it.
Where did those people go?
Why didn't they talk about the
things that are involved in before?
It's interesting that I know you know
about Hitler burned the rice stag and Nero
burned Rome and we know that
this situation has been,
it's happened in history before where
someone has created some sort of an
artificial dilemma to resolve
it and they've done it,
you know,
to pass laws to impose their agenda,
whatever.
But then when someone tells
me that Oklahoma City,
they blew it up just to
pass new terrorism laws,
I go,
get the fuck outta here.
I mean,
yeah,
it's hard of me.
Doesn't want to accept that.
Part of me is,
even though I know that
it's been done before,
there's,
there's a certain,
it's a more complicated web.
It was recently released that the FBI has
been involved in over 50% of terrorist
acts that have occurred on us soil.
What they do is they infiltrate and
then they enable in certain ways and
sometimes they busted him in the
middle or they let it go forward.
It,
I think the first
World Trade Center bombing,
you had the guy with the,
the recording of the,
with the,
the,
excuse me,
the uh,
the agent that was there that was working
with a terrorist and sided with the
FBI and the FBI told him to
go forward with the explosion.
They gave him the bomb to do so,
so that that didn't need to happen.
That's public record really.
So they knew he was going to
blow up the World Trade Center.
They had infiltrated the
group long before noon.
So suspicious.
Yeah,
they led,
they gave him the explosion.
They gave him the detonator,
the FBI handed Salaam,
it was his name and they,
the guy recorded these conversations
because he was so upset by what the FBI
wanted him to do.
All that.
All of that's in the Zike
guys moving companion guide.
By the way.
It's perfectly honest.
I'm so sick of talking about that shit.
Really?
Oh,
it's always the drill there.
God Damn though.
That's unbelievable.
I know about the guy and I
believe it was Dallas where um,
they talked him into blowing something up,
gave him a fake bomb,
set him up and he went and did
it and then they were of them.
I'm like,
that is just,
you found some really dumb guy.
It's easy to see.
If you look at all the warnings
of a Solomon Law and an al Qaeda,
easy to see how that CIA,
FBI agents infiltrated a rogue group
that we're planning to do a terrorist
attack in the world trade center
infiltrated and aided and to make sure it
worked in the way that they wanted it to.
Even after the fact with
industrial industrial organizing,
perhaps with the die in the
first World Trade Center bombing,
I believe a couple of people did.
It wasn't that big though.
I think it was seven people or something.
So they're responsible
for those seven deaths.
And the only reason that didn't bring
down a major been by the way is cause
there was another van
parked in the wrong spot.
It was supposed to be right
by this one support beam.
If it did,
it would have partially imploded down,
partially collapsed again in a whole
lot more people would have died.
So you believe that they could 15
people could have rigged the World Trade
Center towers and over
the course of many months,
yes.
And they could have been planning
this thing out the whole time and Dick
Cheney's got all these don't go so
far to say it has anything to do with
presidents are in like that.
I think it's,
it's a standard operating procedure,
black operation that's,
that's telltale back in time.
And just look at how they operate it
before and they just did it again.
Who uh,
who sets it up?
No,
it's not that obvious.
Corporate interest in Wall
Street are highly intertwined.
CIA and Wall Street
are highly intertwined.
You can't speculate on how this
idea would really come to fruition.
All you could think of is that yes,
you have the options there and you have
the Preston to do so I have no idea
where the source would be.
It it,
it had so many benefits and
so many different levels.
Namely benefit though is
to the administration,
the interest of the oil industry to move
in on the power's in the Middle East
and give the ultimate
precedent and as a side effect,
they were going to orchestrate it though
wouldn't they orchestrated with some
people like if we're going to go to Iraq,
that's the plan.
Would they have Iraqi's attack us?
I don't think they could
have infiltrated it,
but they tried their
hardest dependent on Saddam.
I had one of the first
publications by the way,
that was produced the day
after nine 11 by Time magazine.
It's the most amazing piece of propaganda.
You flipped through it.
You have every horrible shot as
exaggerated as possible and then boom,
you hit,
you hit Osama bin Ladin.
There he is.
Next page,
Saddam Hussein.
the uh,
the guy from Korea.
So they just lined them up psychologically
and he could easily have seen Saddam
was a highlight.
He was sitting there with a big,
big,
big bazooka.
It was hilarious.
I mean it was,
there was this planted as you could
possibly get and which is not a new thing
either.
It's just sad to see how people
have no sense of history.
They don't really understand how
business has been covert for so long.
And then again,
what would you expect?
Big government is a business.
That's what it runs.
It's one big business.
We expect more transparency because
we have so much more information.
Transparency was never
there to begin with.
The only reason that we thought
we'd never had the internet either.
Exactly.
But the reason we think is because now
it starts to leak because of how powerful
than the wikileaks and
people with consciences,
you know,
coming forward and trying to help
and make these things come out.
But um,
it's really going back to the,
the social system,
you know,
flaw.
If it's a survival of the fittest concept,
if it's a competitive system,
doesn't matter whether it's two people
competing for a job to corporations
competing for market share
or two countries competing
for resources and their
own esteem or whatever their
interests are as an empire.
It's the same fundamental logic.
When Julian Assange,
uh,
came out with all this information,
released all this shit,
and what did you think was
gonna Happen to that guy?
I was just disappointed that he chose to
put himself in the forefront because it
painted a picture of a
personality cult of personality,
which I just can't stand.
I didn't know what,
what I,
I figured he would just be,
he would be character
assessed the left and right.
I doubt they would try to do
anything to him physically.
Why do you think he did it?
It was an ego moved to put
himself and it was inadvertent.
I think he had,
he was a spokesman.
It was inadvertent,
but if,
if I had was in that position
of such massive attention,
I would gotten a team to take the
reins and not have one entity that way.
There's less for them to attack.
There's anything that I do in my work,
even though I don't consider
myself to be that famous is I,
I'm always dispersing and getting other
people to do lots of other things and
take the attention away from
myself for many different purposes.
For one,
I don't really feel comfortable with that.
Any type of role as you've,
you've joked about,
it's really not in my
character whatsoever.
Never that you've gotten to this point
that I just feel like I've been pushed.
I,
it's sold like little
Martin Luther King thing.
He's like,
he just felt like a big
Martin Luther King Fan.
He was felt like he was pushed.
So I kind of allow myself to be just be
pushed and I kind of go with the flow,
but there's nothing more important to me
than showing a larger face to this type
of concept and not get caught up
in the cult of personality issue.
So it has a few different psychological,
are you making a living
doing lectures now?
Like what are you doing?
I have never been paid for a lecture.
I make a modest living trying to
commercially now exploit zeitgeists and
occasionally I believe in and I still
do some equity things and we do it.
We have to do in this
system but I so you're out.
They're scamming the people
now I I'm scamming traders.
That's what you
do.
Is that what you do?
It's a little,
it's like a game you play.
It is,
it's all it is.
You do it.
You have to do,
you know I could just be
a bartender somewhere.
You know,
you pick,
you pick your poison,
charge money for lectures.
It seems like I don't like it.
I don't like doing that because people
would be nice to compensate me for
travel.
I appreciate that.
I can't afford to just
flagrantly go out there.
I'll be fly all over the country for free.
Not usually,
but if there's an event I try to hope
that they give me at least something.
It depends on,
it depends on the nature of the event.
Are you guys going to have like
some sort of an annual thing,
like some sort of as like guys party?
We have,
well,
we have,
we have a site guys today,
which is a very intellectual day with a
series of lectures about a dozen of us
that give different lectures
in different subjects.
What do you do that we're
doing this one in Vancouver.
Last year we did it in London.
The before New York.
See,
that's pretty bad ass.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a big pivotal part of the
kind of wellness program we had.
We have had great turnouts.
That's how you meet the guy with the land.
That's how,
that's how the story starts.
You bring it into my laundry.
The guy who does your land.
I was going to fucking set up your,
can you draw a compound?
Who Do you think killed biggie
rampart,
bro.
My captain conspiracy here.
Who killed you?
A,
you're not a conspiracy guy,
are you?
No,
no,
no.
I don't.
I don't care for those.
I see the causality of it.
I don't care for the
idea of conspiracy on,
certainly not into the concept.
As a theme,
people misunderstood the first film as
far as what was said and it became quote,
the greatest conspiracy film of
all time and some press media,
which I thought was a bad,
it was it,
the idea was uncultural fallibility.
Yeah,
religious force.
You have the nine 11 forests and
the of the entire banking more scam.
It was all really a matter of how
publicly manipulated everyone is into to
believing that these things are actually
legitimate and hold up the social
zeitgeisty well I think what you did to
his package it all together in a really
easily absorbable form that
really likes sent the point home.
You know?
And again,
a lot of people started on a path of
thinking that they might not have ever
started on.
Exactly.
That's the watching that
seem to be so amazing.
You know,
you get emails like
you've changed my life.
It's just amazing to
see the response again,
completely inadvertent.
But you have a certain amount of
responsibility because that you feel it.
You know,
I of course I feel it.
I had,
you know,
I don't take myself that seriously though.
I'm just like anybody else.
So anytime I run into somebody that has
a kind of a cult of personality thing,
I really try to shut that
down as fast as possible.
I can't stand being complimented.
Oh,
it's on.
Gets crazy.
You are my hero like that.
Yeah,
I really try.
It meant any chicks with tattoos
your face on yet are out there?
Not that I've seen is a couple of
girls who have your face on their calf.
Definitely the hippie pussy you get.
Must be unbelievable though.
Thrown your way.
I don't know if you're in a relationship,
girls with tattoos.
I think for some reason like
tad tad curls with crystals.
Yeah.
Girls Ready,
ready for you to start that cult.
It's not,
I don't,
I don't have a rock star life
unfortunately or fortunately.
You need to fucking
manage this shit better.
If you need a podcast,
it's not in my character to come on,
man.
That's all well and good.
Let's pretend no one's listening.
Let's pretend that this may be just one
frame and an infinite movie that goes on
forever and makes no sense.
You should be enjoying the shit out of
this and you can enjoy the shit out of
this with rivers of Hippie Pussy.
Let me tell you that Matt.
Fortunately,
unfortunately we do for Peter Joseph,
take them to the olive garden.
If we get,
gave him a podcast.
Peter Joseph every week.
Yeah,
that'd be awesome.
You tell mom,
you got to give me a podcast.
Yeah,
you can have.
All right.
I do a radio show.
I do a radio.
That's okay.
Yuki,
what'd he do?
Is it on regular radio,
blog talk radio that
we do for the movement?
It's just a free,
is it online?
It's online,
so it's a essentially a podcast as well.
It is a podcast.
Just you do more.
Yeah.
Dude,
you could.
You could go on for hours and hours.
I've got to sex squad podcast.
I know you do,
but I mean it's amazing.
You never say you're like one of the most
eloquent guys I think I've ever talked
to.
It's amazing.
I was,
one of the things I was paying
attention to when I was watching your
presentation,
I'm like,
he's speaking so clearly.
He's like,
he's always so good with getting as I,
that's not,
that's not the easiest thing to do for
a person like me who's essentially lived
at least half of my life
doing public speeches,
you know,
either standup comedy or you know,
or,
or acting stuff or
it's not natural to me.
I guess cause I was a musician.
I'm not too afraid to
speak in front of people.
I guess that's part of it just
to be a performer if you will.
But do you feel like at this point you
have like a Zike guys act all and I say
act,
not that it's bullshit,
but almost like with standup comedy,
you know,
you have subjects that you know you're
going to go into and then once you get
into those subjects you have
stuff that you already said.
Oh sure,
sure.
Well it depends on the,
depends on the circumstance.
It's a vast range of stuff.
And I could ramble on about a lot of
other different issues if you want to go
back for it.
I mean,
yeah,
so it's formulaic obviously.
Like,
if I'm addressing occupy Wall Street,
I have a very specific kind of gesture,
I'm going for a little
more anarchic oriented,
you know,
trying to get relate to their value is
a little more angry cause everyone wants
to get routed up and you know,
you really can't be a fired up speech
that we can give the angry Peter Joseph
again.
That's a great way to get to that hip.
He Pussy you gotta be a leader that's
pissed off in any communication you need
strategy.
So I,
I try my best to call or my strategy
just like I'm doing right now with you.
Yeah.
Well
your,
so your,
your main Gig is this now,
I mean this is essentially
what you're doing.
You do your musical Manga,
you said the music's on the sidelines.
I do that as a hobby.
I do,
we do these art festivals and things like
that to kind of make a little fun out
of things.
The socially conscious art
festival we had a while back,
but you know,
the music's on the sidelines.
The film is,
I have a new film coming
out at the end of this year,
so what does that,
it's like I just beyond the Pale and
hopefully by the end of 2012 I'm not
completely set on that,
but it's going to be the
fourth to be a live action one.
I'm not going to give
away too much about it,
but like live action one meaning
it's going to be a documentary,
but it's going to be a very
untraditional documentary.
Um,
again,
I don't want to talk about it because,
but it's going to be,
it's going to be very interesting.
I do a lot of characterised
stablish went with this one.
Um,
this is going to actors in this one.
It's the same ideas,
same pushing forward with
this broad social expansion.
The idea of what a rational society is
and kind of did you see moving forward.
It's going to be a similar
portrayal of the third film,
but in a gestural sense,
which I think I'm excited to do because
I've never done something like that.
Kind of a cool concept to actually
show people as actors moving forward,
creating some new society.
It's not exactly like that.
Now the the fifth film I'll do theirs,
the trilogy,
we're not the trilogy.
The whole series will end
and in the fifth film,
this is building up to the fifth film,
but at the film's going to be
a puppet show we do in a cave,
but
she never fucking marry that Ag.
We're going to have a nice fire.
We're going to lay over some
bear that we just killed a,
as we cleaned the meat,
you'll do your public show,
you'll,
you'll explain [inaudible]
post apocalyptic,
right.
Explain how it all went down.
Right.
Do you think,
uh,
we're,
we're in danger of that.
Do you think we're in
danger of nuclear war?
Is it within our grasp that we're that
stupid that we might start bombing Iran
and they start bombing us?
Big argument is how mature a society is.
You know,
if you have molecular engineering which
has come into fruition and you can have
someone using nanotechnology,
create a off the shelf
with a very small lab,
a very destructive piece of equipment,
the size of this bottle that can wipe
out or poison or do whatever the hell
knows to a very large landmass.
What does that say about the culture
that feels the need to do that?
Because now we have a
rebellion across the world in,
in real terrorism,
not the farce terrorism,
but there really is this angst that's
emerged from all this deprivation from
abuse blow back if you want to look
at it in a Chomsky hundred view.
I think it's a little more complicated
than that psychologically and what's
going to happen.
We have a whole group of people that are
so pissed and they're so deprived that
they begin to have abilities with
technology that far exceed anything like a
grenade or a suitcase bomb.
So nuclear war as an extension
of that seems almost inevitable.
Not to mention the small destructive
patterns that we can have.
I don't think people even realize that
that potential is on the horizon because
our world is so programmed by our daily
experiences were so used to certain
experiences and a level of
those experiences and we're not,
you know,
we're we,
we,
the idea that we're at war to us as some
sort of a vague thing that you see on
television unless you've
actually been over there.
It goes back to the point I made earlier
about the broad collective social
conscious versus the individual.
Until we begin to look at
society in a social way,
when you look at each other as
yourself talking and poetic here,
it's just you can't have social
stability until everyone's taken care of.
If someone's deprived and
go this side of the world,
I'm not safe because they can be dementia.
Dementia can kick in.
Who knows what biases they might emerge,
who they might trigger and boom.
Suddenly a suitcase bomb explodes
behind me at some restaurant.
No one's safe anymore.
With with the technological advancement,
we have the risks because
she meant power plan.
Again,
you have to have a world
conscious view at this stage,
especially with the age of
modern technology and warfare,
or it's just as in the
words of Albert Einstein,
our technology has exceeded our humanity.
He said that when he experienced the,
you know,
the nuclear bomb that he helped engineer,
you seed saw how bad this was.
Even even the,
uh,
the great scientist,
um,
uh,
that's been in the wheelchair.
Hawking,
hawking has stated that he wants
to see everyone get off the planet.
He's,
he feels that we're already doomed.
We have to get in,
populate it for the extension
of the human species.
We have to populate another planet because
there's no way we're going to survive
in this one based on what we're doing.
That's,
these are very smart people
that think these ways.
So a smart people who are studying the
human race as if we're studying a colony
of ants are studying.
Anything else that you
can clearly see where the,
where they're headed.
Yeah.
It's scary unlike anything.
Is it natural?
It's all natural.
It is all natural.
Natural that the,
you know,
I,
someone said this,
I believe it was Mckenna,
that every parasite is a failed Sambia.
Interesting.
Um,
you know,
what they're all trying to do
is find some sort of a mean,
every body is filled with other
sorts of living organisms.
These living organisms,
they work together in synergy.
They work together.
They're,
they're symbiotic.
And that every parasite is like one that
didn't quite work out and just fucked
up and killed the host or jack the host,
or does something terrible to those.
Isn't it possible that
that's what technology is?
The technology is all sort
of sort of some sort of a,
it's some sort of a parasitic
symbiotic thing where it's,
it's in the middle of,
in the middle of helping us.
It's,
it's enlightening us
and it's allowing us to,
to move forward.
It's allowing us to,
to exchange information or
rate never possible before.
But it's also when you,
when you establish the
highest levels of technology,
the often are destructive and it's going
to feed the need for people to try that
shit out and use it.
Well,
there's the flaw of the broad human
psychology isn't this defense posture that
we've,
we've groomed so well.
You know,
it's not the technology
that's the problem.
It's the fucking people
behind the technology store.
Absolutely.
Let,
I mean,
isn't it,
I mean it,
is it almost inevitable that we,
we,
with this kind of power,
we will have this kind of behavior.
Is it almost inevitable that
with ultimate power like that?
Well,
if there isn't a very dramatic change
in the way people think about themselves
and how they relate to the world,
it seems inevitable to me.
How did you develop this line of thinking?
Did you have some sort of a,
a life changing experience
where you're always like,
this just had great influences from,
from Carl Sagan too,
to even even George Carlin and Bill Hicks
and the comedy spectrum coupled with
the scientific community.
It was very influential with me,
both from a cultural standpoint
and a progressive standpoint,
if there's any that's most influential
would have been Carl Sagan as far as
values because he was so in line the
guy and he smoked weed every day Sun.
Which know that I didn't know that Carl
Sagan would smoke weed and just think
about space.
It's what he did.
And he wrote some brute beautiful,
eloquent essays on cannabis use.
Did it.
And I wasn't aware of that.
Yeah,
it was brilliant golf [inaudible] seconds.
Amazing.
So you know,
it's a long value shift and I,
you know,
I went through the same stuff of anger
and everything else and I think a lot of
people do.
And then I met even more people that
fascinated me and a lot of authors,
there's so many brilliant minds out there
from Joc Fresco at Buckminster Fuller
to Nicola frescoes.
The guidance ahead of that Venus project,
is that who he is,
the director of the Venus project.
Yeah.
And the Venus project is,
explain that to me cause they,
this is a,
they are a resource based
economy and is probably,
it is a,
is a,
is a concept,
a encapsulated concept
put forward by Jock,
which goes farther than
a train of thought.
It actually in Po design actually has
design issues that he's come up with
throughout the years.
He's about 95 now and very brilliant,
very brilliant guy.
They basically are promoting very specific
systems and the zeitgeists movement
promotes long trains of thought
without being specific to a design.
We used to be in partnership,
the Venus project in the zeitgeists
movement and you guys fell apart.
There was a falling out
there unfortunately.
What happened?
Hard to explain,
it was a kind of a personality dropoff
of motivations of code for Hippie Pussy.
That's what it was.
They were fighting over
Hippie Pussy Jack Fresco's.
You should be at the top of the
heap when you're 95 years old.
You've been doing this forever and this
young whippersnapper comes along making
it's fucking films like pitch.
I've got a map,
I've got a map for the future.
So this,
uh,
he's very specific as
far as like engineering,
this sort of a society,
industrial designer and social engineer.
Ah,
so he spent a great deal of time doing
it and it's just like Buckminster Fuller,
which I think is a good counterpart.
These are prominent guys that have really
tried to push forward with new ideas
and many different genres.
Not to mention approaches
to the entire social system.
Hi.
Um,
you know,
I watch a lot of things online
and when I sit in front of it,
I do tooth.
I mean I'm,
yeah,
I absorb whatever someone's putting out.
Of course I listened to their message,
but I also,
when I see something like
what Chunk Fresco is saying,
oh,
I tried to look at it as if I was someone.
Uh,
I was someone who is in some sort of
a position of power in government.
You know,
I was someone who was in some
sort of a position of power,
of political influence,
you know,
running the banks,
running the world,
the IMF,
whoever the fuck it is that
pulls the strings for the world.
And I would say,
how do I deal with this guy?
What do I,
what do I,
does this guy a problem?
Is this guy ever going to be for real?
Is this ever going to be an issue
that I have to deal with this,
this guy,
and debate him as to how the
world's resources should be used?
I mean,
is this a,
is that a concern for a guy like that?
I mean,
do you use,
do you think that a guy like him or
like you do you guys have to with
someone?
It depends on how far we go.
I think anyone in the,
you think that right?
Do you think like as far
as like moving forward,
let me give,
you did buy the land and get the
people to start living there.
That's when you would have an issue.
Well,
well I don't,
again,
I don't advocate such a thing.
I don't advocate running from this
system big is your file the FBI file?
They have idea.
If you had to guess.
I thought it was fucking massive.
Right?
I don't know.
I don't know what you don't care if you
started running your very young right
now.
Like how old are you?
39 no,
30 to 32 that's amazing.
Oh,
you're 32 that's incredible.
So when you came out
with the first site guys,
how old were you?
When I was four years ago.
So it was 20 holy Shit.
So you were in your twenties
when you put that together.
That's a very unusual man.
And you're a very unusual talker.
You know,
if,
if you're only 29 that's what you said.
32 32 32 so that's very unusual man.
So what does it,
what do you have to be to be
president 36 something like that.
I'm not going to be president,
but now,
but we for real,
you say that there's someone come along.
I don't believe in the system
that I don't believe in.
The system changes a little bit.
Listen man,
you could run this shit.
Well,
the next project is something called
the global redesign institute,
which can be a nonprofit I'm founding,
which is going to basically
take artists and engineers,
get them together to show how to
redesign and the infrastructure.
But for particular regions in
the most sustainable nonmonetary,
most sustainable,
practical and efficient way possible.
So for example,
you could take Los Angeles,
you could show the public and
conference it completely new,
redesigned that didn't say
have cars sitting at a gas,
excuse me,
sitting at stop lights,
you know,
wasting gas.
How much gas is based in,
but the inefficiency of
the stoplight system,
at least Europe has those
roundabouts semi better.
But you could think of all sorts of
creative means up and over systems.
You know,
a lot of cars they stop and they
shut off actually at red lights.
Now.
That's good.
That's smart.
But then when you leave,
when you want off the gas,
they start again.
New Technology.
I've seen that with a
couple with batteries stuff.
Yeah.
It's a engines as well.
Um,
so the machine engine,
we see how the concept of efficiency is,
is vast pressure transducers and
streets that can power the lights.
You know,
he'd grab pressure transducers and
these walls that could help power the
lighting system in the building.
There's so many things that
could be applied to society
to make it so grandiose,
efficient that would rule out
the market system by default.
But it would solve so many problems of
poverty and hunger and even conflict and
petty crime and most
crimes related to money.
You know,
you can eliminate so many massive things,
not a utopia if you just applied
the most efficient means.
And give people,
you know,
vertical farms with the coast of Los
Angeles running d sound as processes from
the water boom,
organic vertical farms
feed everyone locally.
Forget globalization.
Think of how much energy
is wasted on globalization,
moving shit back and forth.
Product made here in China,
assembled over here in Uganda.
You know,
it's nuts.
What we're doing.
When you take that stand point,
you begin to see how yes,
you can feed everybody on this planet.
You can have everyone
having access abundance.
We call it on this planet.
It doesn't mean you have
everything you want.
That's impossible.
The very idea of having
everything possible,
which is the catalyst,
everybody can't be the salt.
Number nine,
well everyone can have a 50 room mansion
or two jets parked in the front lawn.
That's actually an act of violence.
If you think about it,
social violence,
it is.
There's an act of violence to think
that way because you're the amount of
deprivation you're
imposing on somebody else.
By that acquisition of resources,
which was so excessive is in fact
inhibiting other people's lives one way or
another.
So wait a minute.
By having a jet or whatever,
how big that is of such an such access.
And you can be subjective on this,
but anything that has no utility,
it's of such access and vanity such as
one guy living with his small family and
a 40 room mansion and having to massive
gas guzzling jets parked in the front
lawn just because he can.
Who does that Travolta Travolta.
Does he do that?
Yep.
Well listen,
you got to fly that Dick in from
all over the world to make sure,
but we'll have to keep quiet
fox magic and he goes so far,
I get that argument though.
Someone says to me,
well I don't like your system cause
what if I want to have four Ferrari's as
though that's a utility need.
It's a complete value orientation.
I say,
well what if I want to
have Africa is my backyard?
Is that okay?
What if I want to block off Africa?
Africa is might be,
that's this form can buy Africa if you
have so much money that you could slowly
buy up the entirety of Africa.
But you see the point by Africa.
So is there a,
is this a competitive society as
their competition in this society?
Competition would be within
one square development,
which is when real competition
is about accelerating yourself,
not against somebody else.
You know,
I could completely see how people in like
a sports it advanced society and like
a sports context,
they're not really thinking
about beating somebody else.
They thinking about beating themselves,
thinking of improving
their own betterment.
It doesn't become something.
The process somebody gets beaten up.
That is a lot of the,
a lot of the motivation,
you know,
if you ever talked to anybody,
very competitive,
it's not just about them
performing at their best,
it's about winning.
I'm sure it is.
Sure it is.
If that's what the culture be enforced,
everything's about winning
culture definitely reinforces it.
But it's also,
I think a piece piece of human
nature is involved in that as well.
It's two universal.
It's not just this culture.
It's pretty much any culture where
any sort of competition starts going.
You know,
people,
people want to win.
You know,
it's a,
it's a natural thing and I think it might
be one of the reasons why it's driven
innovation to such a
radical tipping point.
You talked to anyone who knew Steve
jobs or anybody who knows Bill Gates.
One of the things I'll tell you is how
incredibly competitive these guys are.
Very competitive.
I think it exists on a
different level though,
and it was a lot of flexibility to it.
I'm not denying that it exists,
but for me,
I'm,
I'm not competitive.
I have no interest in the,
but you're also not the head of Microsoft.
You're not putting out computers.
You know what I'm saying?
You know,
done an amazing thing creatively.
But in order to push innovation,
in order to push a company to
push success and achievement,
if you must feel like you have to have
some sort of a sense of competitive on a
market system in variable,
you have to be competitive.
If you're going to fail,
you're gonna fail financially.
You're going to fail in your status.
If you look at Steve jobs writings and
his talks and the guy was a very creative
individual that you could
tell that as money aside.
He wasn't motivated by
that incentive for one.
And I think his interest
to be competitive,
it was really just to make the best he
could for whatever demographic or concept
or idea and of course to
compete against Microsoft
to make sure he maintains
his market share.
So competition is inherent to
the game that they're playing.
That's,
I guess that's my point.
Who knows though,
you know,
am I competitive with other people?
It depends on the context of and also
the conditioning within that context of
what I'm doing.
If I have to survive and have to
go into a fight with somebody,
well that's an obvious competition.
That's something that my
life might depend upon.
So obviously there's something ingrained
there that means we respond that way.
But again,
back to the,
you know,
the,
the later existence of
the prefrontal Cortex,
we don't have to operate that.
When someone goes into a bar and steps
on my foot or insults my girlfriend,
I don't have to beat the shit out of him.
I could say,
Huh,
there's another dip shit,
one of many and walk away or I can save.
There's another victim of cultures,
all sorts of responses that we could
have that are not based on that reaction.
Yeah,
there's certainly a lot of fights.
You're going to void.
I was having that conversation
with someone today.
It's like,
you know,
avoid everything you can.
If you can get out of something,
talk to someone and get out of it.
Get out of it.
What are you crazy and you want
to get in fights with people.
Oh,
it's amazing.
This guy interviewed James Giligan
who was like guy moving forward.
He's one of the most,
one of the most,
uh,
claimed a criminal psychologist and he
would talk about shame and the issues of
shame and why people behave so violently
spent his whole life analyzing violent
behavior.
Grave gave a great insight into serial
killers and a lot of people that you
think are natural outgrowths,
they're just typical of the
system or typical of humanity,
if you will,
and he found it on those
throughout the entire thing.
It was based on a form
of humiliation and shame,
and what was so fascinating is that the
majority of the instances of violence
happened in the most mundane
and arbitrary circumstances.
It wasn't life threatening.
Someone would literally insult somebody
else and they would get really upset by
that and the shame that they would feel
from being so small from getting upset
from someone saying,
fuck you,
caused that much more reinforcement of
their anger to get into a physical brawl.
It was fascinating.
It's a fascinating subject.
I recommend anyone that's interested
in violent behavior to look up.
James Giligan.
Well,
you know,
I am a huge student of human nature,
especially human contact and conflict
and aggression and retrain as a fighter,
right?
Yeah.
I've done martial arts my whole life and
I think that's a huge part of being a
human being.
I think every man,
if you're going to have to deal with
some form of aggression in your life,
you're going to ultimately worry or
wonder what happens if this becomes
physical.
And I think taking that off the table
and learning martial arts as it just as
the animal human being is
a great way to prevent m.
Anybody ever fighting?
I've never seen a fight at a Dojo.
I've never seen a fight at a,
at a Jujitsu gym.
I've never seen a fight.
I mean I,
I've,
I've never seen a fight between fighters.
You know,
Mo for the most part,
most fighters they can communicate better
because they know that they don't want
to fight.
Like they don't have anything to prove.
They know exactly what they can
look at.
The philosophy of Bruce Lee.
I mean,
he was amazing.
There's a few,
I mean there's been a few brawls
post-fight brawls cause the people get an
emotional and there's a famous one on
cvs a while back where mayhem Miller and
the Diaz brothers went at it on CBS.
It was kind of ridiculous.
But yeah,
I mean for the most part though,
the amount of altercations that you're
going to get if you're hanging around
train martial artists are way fewer,
you know,
a amongst themselves,
they're very rare and it either you put
them amongst any other group of athletic
aggressive individuals,
you're going to have much more conflict.
I think you take it
off the table once you,
uh,
address it and you understand it.
It's like with a lot of people,
the idea of kicking someone's ass really
a big part of it is that they don't
want their own ass kicked.
It's a fear.
It's like an overconfidence
initial fear.
Yeah,
no,
totally.
Totally.
It is.
We need to figure this fucking thing out.
Peter Joseph,
goddammit,
we're closing in on it.
We're clone is closing in on some,
some real,
uh,
interesting lessons.
Well,
if you want them,
I can go back to your question,
I guess from like 20 minutes ago regarding
what the system would be if I was the
leader of it,
which is a farce notion,
but what would the firing,
I said King,
what would,
what would define a new value system?
What would define a new sense
of operation and if you track,
you track a fundamental train of thought.
You arrive at a series of conclusions.
The first is he get rid of the property
system as we know it and you create an
access system.
Best example is the Zipcar New York.
Amazing.
I love that.
I love the ZIP car.
People don't know.
Explain it.
It's amazing.
Zipcar is just a rental car
that's very easily accessible.
It would be special keys
and they come and they'll,
they'll drop the car off or they'll
leave it at a place that's close to you.
It's all proximity oriented,
computer generated and basically you can
have a car and drive it and then return
it and it's like a rental car
except it's more convenient.
That's beautiful.
Most people's cars sit and driveways
for the majority of their life.
That's a great idea.
Access access system versus a system of
property is the most efficient concept
of social,
excuse me,
of environmental management.
You can have think about it.
It's so stupid for everyone.
I've,
I've so much film equipment
stuffed in like closets.
I would love to just to rent it,
but I can't do it cause I had no value.
I have to get to resell it.
I'd spend much more money renting this
stuff over and over again and then owning
it so it goes against it.
And then monetary sense,
monetarily inefficient
car concept is a great idea for someone
who wants to live in a place like New
York City where it's just prohibitively
expensive to try to have a parking spot
anywhere.
If you had,
if you had a society designed,
first of all,
if you're in an inner city,
you really want to get public transit
working well because that's the best way
to do it.
Anyway,
we,
there's so many failures.
I,
my great grandfather was an engineer
and he had designed the system in Los
Angeles years ago,
many years ago,
which was a trolley system that was above,
above ground,
wasn't,
wasn't uh,
susceptible to two earthquakes.
It was brilliant.
And I was like,
why didn't they put this in back then?
It was like one of the first
transit ideas for Los Angeles.
And even to this day,
you have a,
you know you have the,
you have the subway,
but that's nominal.
It doesn't really go anywhere and
you have these cars just coming here.
I was just want to blow my brains
out in traffic and cars and he said,
you can't keep operating like this.
Eventually.
They're gonna do what
they do in Latin America.
They're going to have you
driving by license plate number.
You know,
they do that in Latin America.
You can't even drive and uncertain times.
I mean,
what's going to happen,
population can use to increase and we
had these inefficient systems in place.
We need it to.
Mexico City's like that right now.
No sure.
Mexico City.
It's just unbelievable.
Always traffic.
Just traffic all day.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous.
Even in China,
they've been moving out the
bikes or they've been trying
to motivate consumerism
in China to get people to buy cars.
Why is this good for GDP?
Oh Great.
So they can create more air pollution
and create more congestion on their
streets as well.
Everything is antithesis.
The opposite.
It's an anti economy.
It ass backwards from top to bottom
with the way we approach our economic
structure.
So how do we fix it?
We have to wait for it to fall apart.
It's wait for him our own shit and
then we have to show the audit show.
As I mentioned,
the global redesign institute.
You have to show the world and alternative
that they can understand to see how
these problems can be resolved.
And then I advocate a parallel government
system as radical as that statement
sentence.
I have her low government
one government well appear.
Well you have the existing government
in whatever region or in its holistic
sense as far as say the United Nations,
if you will.
The parallel system would be a group of
people that are not politicians and not
jockeying for public support and public
opinion manipulating the values and
abortion and gay rights,
this and gay marriage that they,
those to become nominally obsolete
because they are completely irrelevant
culturally compared to
what the problem is.
We have the group of technicians and
engineers and thinkers and creators that
want to simply design the infrastructure
of society correctly to meet the needs
of the human population.
And with that train of thought,
I guarantee you people will
be chomping at the bit,
volunteer to show what they can do to
make society more efficient and as a side
product of that money,
it goes out the window.
Because if you really
detailed the issue of money,
you can't have an efficient system
in the market model of economics.
Truly efficient.
It's impossible.
One final point,
green economy,
everyone must up a green economy,
right?
The green economy books
written on green economy.
Green economy is impossible also in a
monetary system because of the inherent
flaw of cost efficiency,
needing to cut corners to get the right
product to make it so people can buy it.
The inherent flaws of
cyclical consumption,
the need to have constant turnover.
Our Sis,
our economic system is in one big
paradox and the old economic theory,
it says there's scarcity.
Therefore we have to have it.
The assumption of Social Darwinism that
some people who can have the right to
this through their equity and some
cannot never enough to go around as the
assumption simultaneously.
It's based on infinite
growth simultaneously.
It assumes that we have to constantly
keep consuming so people can stay employed
and with the growing population where you
have to have more and more consumption
to keep.
Everyone that's populating employed
clearly hasn't been planned out.
There's no planning.
It's all been,
which is understandable and our evolution,
this is weird,
we are a monkey cells trying to
figure out what the fuck's going on,
but luckily we can begin to assess.
We can see the the light and now it's
the big conundrum of how to get the fuck
out of this system and it is something
that actually works without seeing too
much destruction without,
without seeing too much breakdown.
I don't want to see the system fail
and the infrastructure completed be
demolished.
I want to see terrorists
come out of the woodwork.
I don't want to see a,
we've got to get people on mushrooms stat.
That's what's going on,
man.
The only way we're going
to fix these fluxs.
We've got to get them on mushrooms.
No Way.
People are gonna make some
just radical leap of change.
They're going to recognize,
just like they recognize right now in
other parts of the country where there's a
leadership vacuum,
you know whether it's in Iraq right now,
there's a rack going
through a fucking civil war.
Congratulations from America.
We just fucked up another
spot in the world.
One of many dictators
going to move into place.
Some new ruthless motherfucker
who dominates the situation.
Meet the new boss.
Same as the old boss,
right?
As long as they're in favor
of western geopolitics,
there'll be safe.
Yeah,
maybe.
Right?
What the fuck do we do,
Peter?
Joseph?
Do we wait for the aliens?
Are They not real god?
I really wished aliens would come.
They would have set a great precedent,
wouldn't it?
We'd actually be able to see another
entity that that actually was beyond us
that could actually give us the obvious
awareness that we're one species.
I wouldn't have one family.
That's the Ronald Reagan's speech.
Is it?
Do you remember Ronald Reagan?
So I don't,
I don't remember that one now.
He gave a speech during the middle of
the Cold War saying that a how quickly we
would unite as a,
as a,
as a race once,
if we were faced with a threat from
another world and everybody got crazy.
Like damn the fucking aliens are coming.
Ronald Reagan just letting us know.
I agree.
Nothing happened.
I had a great idea for a film.
It was a bunch of hackers.
They go,
and I shouldn't give this away,
but I doubt it.
I'll give it a wedding would make it,
well,
I'll give you the premise cause it's fine.
I'll do it and it'll be online.
They're going to steal it.
Well I hope they steal it.
Okay,
there you go.
Put that information out.
We have a whole group of hackers,
right?
So they hack into the u s Pentagon and
hack into the military systems that are
interconnected around the world and they
find gay porn and they plant a fake,
a fake asteroid attack
coming towards the earth.
So all the media now thinks there's a
ginormous asteroid coming towards earth
that will destroy all of humanity.
What happens?
The motivation of all the continents,
they come together,
they try to combine their resources.
They try to create some type
of anti asteroid weapon,
and then suddenly someone figures out
that these are just a bunch of hackers and
they're brought in chains and then they
give this nice speech at the end of how
this was their attempt to unify
humanity before it was too late.
It's like a Scooby doo episodes.
It's going to be duped.
They're hackers trying to save humanity.
It'd be a good ploy.
I think it would.
I think the audience would like that,
especially if the audience didn't know
they were hackers at the beginning.
They thought it was all real until
they came forward and I could work.
Who Do you think was how you
don't play the leading Broderick?
Would you go with Kristin from twilight?
What's her name?
Kristen Stewart.
She would be good right here.
These to be one of your good stars.
Who's this?
Matthew Broderick and more games.
Of course.
You know,
it's amazing.
I like watching the alien,
the original alien,
what they thought that the cockpit of
a like a sophisticated computer setup
would look like.
This is so wonky.
No,
no.
A graphic user interface at all.
I'll just like numbers and
letters and it's interesting.
It's interesting to see what people think
about the future and what it ends up
being.
We can do it predicting space,
travel to other planets,
no problem,
but but figuring out a
graphic user interface.
It just really never then whatever
wrapped their head around it yet so hard
to predict what the future may hold.
Man.
Do you think the technology can save us?
Is it possible that there's going to be
something that comes along that creates
some sort of a connectivity with
human beings that allows us to be more
empathetic to the idea or or
more accepting to the idea
that we are really truly
one species,
that we are a super organism?
Well in the words of Carl
Sagan when he was approaching,
you know,
the nuclear fallout possibility
during the Cold War.
He said,
if there's anything like positive
that could come out of this,
it will be the unification of humanity
on the level of really realizing that
they are all at risk by the
actions of just two small,
seemingly small superpowers.
This is a pivotal thing.
Someone's breakdown,
a society occurs once people see
how interconnected things are in the
infrastructure of society.
In fact that computers
run everything already.
You know,
it's very obvious the symbiosis and I
think come to fruition if there's any
pattern that's become more of a trend now.
It's the oneness poetry.
I'd look at it very literal,
but a lot of people would like to
take it into a metaphysical sense.
The unification of the species is not
just the unification of us as a family in
a gestural sense.
Even though you can go back,
you know,
to the mitochondrial eve
many thousands of years ago,
we all have the same basic
mitochondrial DNA construct.
We all come from that basic
kernel one way or another,
the entire species.
But the entire association of values
in our minds is utterly symbiotic.
It's the group mind.
It's a collective consciousness.
If you want to use that old term,
I use the group mind.
It's no more practical
everything you think.
Everything I think has been
communicated to us one way or another.
Filtered through a basic
genetic preprogram combined
with all sorts of other
data coming from other people,
so no one originates any may anything.
No one thinks in any kind of novel sense.
It's all an illusion and is anything
that could show the unification of the
species on that level.
As far as what we think we are,
we can only be everything because
there are very constructive thought is
determined by what
everyone else is thinking,
feeding into us through information,
whether it's your parents,
whether it's your educational
system so there's no,
there's no way to rationalize separation,
you know what I mean?
And other molecular quantum field level,
if you want to jump to that route,
it's all a big sea of molecules
moving around just this.
This is all a big illusion.
I think we all know that by now,
right?
Well,
if you get to that,
how much do you think that you can
manipulate your environment and with
thinking,
how much do you think?
Well,
the beauty of the tech technology
as an extension of ourselves,
is it the ultimate tool with mean
thinking really is a technological idea,
logic and reason,
which came to us just a couple thousand
years ago with Aristotle with finally
figured out how to think.
Even though most of the
is still doesn't do that,
these tools will lead to something
and if the values are right,
if we see the rationale,
if we see the reason,
if we see what it means to relate
to the environment is very,
very simple.
If we see the benefit of automation as a,
as an isolated example,
we naturally adapt and adjust.
And what's happened now though,
I mean frankly there isn't a crisis.
There's only the crisis
of the way we think.
There's no reason you couldn't turn
all this around tomorrow if he wanted
it to somebody who makes a terminator.
Well,
the older fantasy a take over by machines.
I,
I'm certainly amused by,
but amused were already taken over.
We're already taking everybody I know,
but I mean,
what if it's like literal?
Yeah,
there's no,
you don't think so?
There's nothing in there that that I could
see programming wise that would allow
for such a thing.
The,
the ultimate expression of
that was that hideous film I,
robot at the very end,
the computer goes,
we add to exterminate all of humanity
because they are a threat to the planet.
So are logical calculation that
humanity can no longer exist.
That's the ultimate Scifi fantasy of
artificial intelligence wasn't necessary,
but that's a big budget.
Will Smith Film and they got
to do what they gotta do.
Of course,
as as an idea of,
but that's that catered to the long
standing assumptions of artificial
intelligence and automation
and technological singularity.
You sure?
And as Curtis ballpoints though,
we don't really know what will happen
with the technological singularity,
but technology becomes sentient and
as the ability to move and manipulate
things,
who knows?
Well,
if there are,
if they are extensions of us,
they become our tools.
Who's to say we want to program
them to kill it says who says us?
That's what we were talking about earlier
about failed symbiotic show that the,
the parasitic relationship between,
I mean the symbiotic right now,
relationship between human
beings and computers.
It's very similar to if you look at
like other organisms that have a,
you know,
lampreys on sharks or whatever.
I mean we're almost separable.
We're a part of the same
sort of ecosystem now.
We need the lights to stay on,
we need their refrigerator to stay cold
so that we can preserve the meat better.
I mean we,
we have it sort of set out so we're
almost completely intertwined with
technology and habitable
and then we give birth,
the live one,
we give birth to technology where it's
sent in and we're could figure shit out
on own and it becomes another life form.
It becomes a life form.
Much like a biological
carbon based life form.
Just completely different and unexpected
and something we didn't see coming.
Just like,
you know,
it's all very possible.
You mean,
do you ever like look at look
broken computers and shit?
Those are bodies.
It was a dead body.
Sure,
sure.
It's fucking dinosaurs.
But they're happening really quickly
at this stage of our evolution.
Either we,
uh,
utilize technology to help us and hope
for the best or we're going to perish
anyway.
So if it happens to be,
we become enslaved by a
bunch of machines in the NFL,
so be it.
That must be a natural evolution.
So you're cool with that
given what's at stake today.
I'm cool with that.
Given what we have to deal with.
I'm perfectly happy to be robots like
that is now I'm going to be on the
Internet.
Peter Joseph.
Cool with robots taking over.
Hey,
I'm cool with that.
Cool.
This is,
this is like ice movements,
primary premise.
We're cool with robots taken.
I will say this if the Fallis,
the f the problem of human psychology
is so vast now that I can only dream of
the cold quality of calculation coming
forward to save us because we've fucked
up just about everything so far.
We are way beyond our
sense of self control.
That's what calculated society is.
That's what our brain does.
It's a calculation
process and it's too bad.
We're so clouded these us and
them issues.
And all these things that
are evolutionary baggage.
Exactly.
And again,
it's easy to see an amazing,
beautiful society and marriage if we
simply wanted to construct one correctly
cause we have that power
now and we have mushrooms.
That's important.
That's an important part of the equation.
I don't think you're going to fix people
without some sort of a large scale
psychedelic experiment.
I did see an evolution special that
alluded to that old Bill Hicks joke,
which may be came true that mushrooms
could have been that link that pushed
forward.
The human brain.
Just theory,
the stoned ape theory.
Exactly what you probably saw.
Yeah.
He said that it was in a more
academic circle too though,
is actually more than just Mckenna.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of scientists that
have speculated it because you know,
the,
the incredible powers
of psychedelic plants.
I mean as far as like,
uh,
powers of experience.
I mean if you don't know,
if you never had it,
there's a lot of people
ignorant to the experience.
You've done mushrooms before.
I have you just wink if you're worried
about the PR you everything in high
school and college.
So if you've had a real big experience,
a big trip,
you realize how humbling
it is first of all,
just to know that that's possible.
That that's even an experience that a
person can have and that they're not dying
from it either.
And then I know,
oh,
we have a lot of friends that have had
gone through crazy psychedelic trips and
everyone's okay.
But the,
the,
the experience itself,
to someone who's uninitiated,
it's almost impossible
to imagine like you,
you can't imagine that it's really
possible that this could exist.
And then this is not discussed every day
on CBS evening news that someone's not
saying,
listen man,
you need to get on mushrooms.
Okay,
you need to find a fucking place where
you're comfortable and you need someone
who gets you the good shit.
And he need to go there with clear tent.
And you need to do yoga and need to
find yourself because life can be way
better.
And this recent John Hopkins study
with a dark talked about one dose.
They had one large dose of Psilocybin and
they had measurable increases in their
happiness,
their personality over a
period of like 20 years
reset their whole life.
Right?
So could we need [inaudible]
add mushrooms to the psyche
in harmony and Fox match?
We Need Fox.
It was so weird,
by the way,
I,
I'm still trying to figure it out.
Rupert Micro Rupert as our whole Fox
magic thing where he believes in Fox and
well,
let's,
let's be real honest.
He was high as fuck.
I'm not familiar with time.
And if you get that guy sober,
we probably would've never said that.
He knows Fox magic.
He's an interesting cat,
you know,
but you have to be that guy.
You know,
he's not,
he's,
he's a,
he's out there,
man.
He's,
he's not following any of the status quo.
That guys out there trying to expose
corruption in the government at every,
every step of the way.
You have to be a little,
a little,
uh,
I dunno.
Loony.
He's got a,
here's a hero.
Quality to him is,
he's out there.
He's doing it.
You can't really fuck with amazing.
It's a good guy too.
You could tell he's a good guy.
He's a good guy.
When you talk to him and
he's not an asshole south,
they're doing the right thing.
You need people like that.
Right?
Brian Fox,
magic bitches,
12 Fox magic t shirts.
Send them out there and then Peter,
Joseph and quotes.
I'm cool with the robots taking over.
That's how we're going to
make you some money man.
Market you.
All right.
Um,
this is very cool conversation.
Is there anything else you want to say?
Is there anything that
people need to know about?
Well,
shit,
there's tons of things I
could say and tons of things.
I mean,
we got events coming up.
I'm going to be in New York.
If anyone's in New York at the end
of this month in Colombia to hook up,
go for some drinks.
What is the best way to
find out information?
What is your number one website?
I know it's,
it's Tz movement on
those like guys movement,
[inaudible] movement on Twitter.
That's for the movement.
What is the best way to be informed?
What website can people go to?
May Movement side is just simply the
zeitgeists movement.com and then the movie
side does zeitgeisty movie.com and then
you can link to all the other sub sites
for the films and there's a bunch of scam
sites that like they said like I guess
film series has been subject to more
manipulation and scam and resellers.
I've been screwed over so extensive by
attempting to be altruistic with the
distribution of that film.
People buy things from me,
resell it,
profit all over the place.
I just now stopped doing a lot of things
I used to do after four years cause I,
I'm running out of money.
I can barely see myself
making this new film.
It's going to be quite the
quite the difficult venture,
but it's like just has
attracted just about everything,
whether it's people that want to abuse it,
people that hate me,
people that like it does.
No,
no more strange phenomenon I've come
across recently and in the Zike guys
phenomena.
As far as a cultural issue.
It's really strange and I'm just imagining
it must be a pretty big life change
to go from just being
a classical musician,
right?
To all of a sudden at the head of
some crazy movement where you're being
critiqued and criticized for every
single word that comes anyway,
probably were critiqued.
People gonna be mad at you for
even doing this stupid show,
this ridiculous show.
We make fun of everything.
You know?
I think it's important to realize that
we're all just people and no one should
take any of them said
anyone that seriously.
I,
I have a great deal of
humor with all of this.
I,
I have the Carlin level,
I call it sitting on the sideline and
that's something I don't readily admit,
but the Carlin level,
George Carlin is where you
just don't give a shit anymore.
And as much as I push
forward with all of this,
there's a side of me that says,
you know what?
It is what it is.
If myself,
if my partial,
excuse me,
if I become just deeply unhappy
and he get tired of what I'm doing,
then I'm gone.
And it is what it is.
I'm not,
I don't owe anybody anything.
If people out there support such ideas,
they need to become their own
leaders and really push this forward,
learn,
educate,
and do the same process
that I had been doing.
There's nothing special here.
So there's anything I would leave to the
audience that actually has an activist
bone.
It's that don't,
don't follow anybody.
You got to get out there and do it.
Cause a lot of these people
that are at trying to lead,
if you will,
are not going to be around forever.
I could hit the car loan level and say,
fuck it.
Evolutionary called Osac goodbye
humanity and I can go live on the moon
somewhere after I do
something on the fly there
at the compound outside Sanoma,
the car,
the zeitgeists compliment their
growing hippie pussy on trees.
Well,
thank you very much man.
As a very fun conversation.
Thank you.
I appreciate you.
That fascinating.
Um,
again,
uh,
all the information,
the zeitgeists movement,
the website is one more time,
the Zike guys,
movement.com and a Tz movement on Twitter.
And,
um,
and you're also have a Facebook page,
was a Facebook page,
like have an official on Facebook.
If you search that one.
This is like guys movement official.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
To the flashlight for all Chicago us.
No,
January 27th,
right?
Is that the next day?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's the Chicago theater.
There's still some tickets left.
Uh,
it's a,
a huge place.
It's going to be me,
Joey Diaz and Duncan Trussell
and it should be a fucking blast.
And that's January 27th.
And,
uh,
I'm looking forward to that because that's
the night after or the night before,
whether the UFC fights on Fox,
um,
is the show's sold out tonight.
Show sold out tonight.
But,
uh,
a friend of ours is a,
you know,
died in a car accident and was in a,
uh,
um,
he's in the other guys in the hospital.
It'll still,
yeah,
it's a famous,
a lot of people heard about it.
He's a standup comedian.
His name was Josh Myers
and there's a website,
donate a Angelo Bowers
is the one that died.
Uh,
but yeah,
there's a website set up to that.
You can help Josh because he's going
to be in debt for the rest of his life
because of all these,
I mean he's alive.
Thank God.
But,
but it's donate for josh.com
if you can spare anything.
Thank you very much ladies.
Gentlemen,
thanks to the flashlight
for sponsoring the podcast.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and
were in the code name Brogan and you'll
get 15% off.
Number one sex toy for men.
Thanks to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement,
new mood,
the serotonin boosting five HTP supplement
and shroom tech and shrimp tech sport
shroom tech,
immune to different mushrooms,
pop supplements that are all,
all the information is available
on [inaudible] dot com and uh,
and why are 12 is the code to enter.
And if you enter that,
you will get 20 point 12%
off until January 9th.
So go get some dirty bitches.
Thanks for tuning in.
Uh,
we will see you next week.
We've got a,
a bunch of cool people coming
in and a good times ahead.
And as always,
we love all of you.
Dirty bitches,
all of you.
We'll see you tonight in
the ice house chronical.
Yeah.
We'll see tonight in
the icehouse chronicles.
That's right on the desk squad label.
It'll be on this,
uh,
this Ustream,
if you're watching on Ustream,
is same one on the Joe
Rogan Ustream channel.
But if you were a on a iTunes,
it can only be found on the
desk squad label on iTunes.
So subscribed to that shit.
Alright.
See a freaks.
Yeah.